Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you.
I'm just checking on you.
I hope this isn't too loud.
Hope it doesn't make too much noise.
I'm on the road.
Um,
so you get even even more of the bootleg experience Echo.
For some reason I am in a hotel room that has,
I would say,
Oh,
if I had to guess a 18 foot ceilings and no,
this is not some super swanky frigging place.
I think it's just an old building and uh,
and people were shorter back then walking around and wool suits all,
you know what it was,
they wore hats,
they wore big hats back then.
That was it.
That was the deal.
It was like probably no one guys is probably know whoever had the biggest fancy
his hat
that the women back then with the hoop skirts for probably all like,
oh,
he probably got,
he's probably got all the money.
He's probably got all kinds of money.
Right.
Um,
of course,
you know,
psychologists would probably say that.
It was,
that was all about Dick size.
You know what I mean?
I don't think any guy really thinks about dick size unless he has a little Dick.
Other than that,
if you fucking,
you know,
it's like I'm an average runner.
I never think of,
no,
I actually wasn't.
I was slow and I never even thought about that.
Okay.
You know what the reality comes down to,
okay.
It's not about Dick size.
It's about how much fucking money you make.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
You meet some broad none bar.
What does she say?
How big is your Dick?
She doesn't.
She says,
what do you do?
All right.
Are you worth my time tonight?
You know,
and even when she's out there just trolling for some cock,
you know what I mean?
And she's doing a little fucking checking your feet and your hands maybe taking
a glance down to see how you're hanging.
Right.
If he was some dockers and he was sitting down,
I don't know how the fuck they would tell fright.
Um,
she showed up in the barn sweatpants
at some point,
even if she's out there just to get bank,
she is going to ask you what you fucking do.
They can't help.
And then I guess part of it is,
you know,
you want to get past the awkward conversation and that is,
what do you do is also like,
you know,
hey,
can you believe this weather?
Yeah.
Hey,
can you believe this weather?
What do you do?
How big is your Dick?
You know,
Bang,
Bang.
And they go right down the thing.
And then that's when they determine if there's going to be a white one night
stand.
If they're going to pretend
you know,
that they're not just some size queen and that,
that,
you know,
maybe they go and they'll start talking about their family.
You know what I mean?
That's when you know you're fucked.
They started talking about their family.
It's like,
Oh God,
not this.
I always hope when you were just going to treat me like a piece of meat,
now you won't have a fucking relationship.
Fuck,
I should've lied about my job.
Um,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
As always.
I have no idea what the fuck I'm talking about.
Am I contractually obligated,
even though there's no contract on this podcast,
it's a verbal contract and I honor it.
Unlike what happened to Jakey Lee and a bunch of other musicians when they
played with for a certain somebody that everybody thinks is cute.
Yeah.
Oh,
Sharon Sharon,
how can Pharma we glad you remember all that shit.
I went down and fucking Jakey Lee,
Randy Rhoads.
Um,
I dunno what you call Brown down a rabbit hole.
And then that led me to bring up,
I always read up on that fucking case where the original drummer and bass player
never got played on,
uh,
you know,
was it blizzard of Oz and diary of a madman as well?
The two albums,
I don't fucking know.
And they actually asked for the money for paying on those things.
So they fucking,
oh wait.
They ended up buying the rights to the album.
It was fucking enclosed.
It was,
I got the second,
it was a mini series.
It was like the Oj trial,
except with like recording.
So then are the Izea camp rerecorded the drums and the bass on it.
It's fucking unreal.
I mean,
let me look that shit up.
Let me look that up here as I'm just sitting here battling.
Um,
but anyways,
Jakey Lee,
what a fucking player.
I know Randy Rhodes is just unreal but shaky Lee never,
he never gets his,
he never gets a fucking shout out.
It goes,
it goes from fucking,
you know,
obviously Hendrix,
and then they'll throw some Clapton in there,
then they go to Jimmy page and then boom.
Then it's like Eddie van Halen.
There's like before Eddie and after a,
when it comes to white guys shredders and then they always go to Randy Rhoads
and then they skip right past
it seems they skip right past Jakey Lee and then they go right to that guy from
white lion.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what it is.
No,
cause I've done,
I think they get into the gut.
The fucking speed metal guys.
I have no idea.
All right,
let's see.
Drummer for
blizzard of Oz.
Blizzard of all.
See?
Uh,
yeah,
we Kerslake new by the way,
just let himself go to health.
Christ Almighty.
He looks like he sold tires his whole fucking life.
That's how much stress,
this whole thing case,
um,
took on the guy.
Okay.
All right.
After being fired,
wait a minute.
Where are we?
List of Osborne,
Osborne band members.
He doesn't even have his own fucking Wikipedia page.
Jesus Christ at Ozzy.
He has some fucking guitarist or what?
Okay.
Randy Rhoads.
Jakey Lee,
Zack Wylde,
Steve Vai.
I don't know any of these other fucking guys.
Broody Syrah,
Sasso on base.
Come on,
man.
Isn't that crazy?
He had both fucking,
uh,
bass players surviving based players from Metallica.
Roberta Hilo.
He came in and rerecorded the basis basis.
You record the bass,
I guess.
Jason Newstead,
Tommy Aldridge.
I ran into him and fucking Belgium freaked him out because I was freaking out.
And then I didn't ask for a picture.
He looked relieved.
It's just like,
sorry,
man.
Thank you for all the great music you've,
you've given me.
I really appreciate it.
He goes,
all right,
cool.
And that was it.
All right.
I'm going to get off this fucking subject.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
I am in Saint Petersburg,
Florida.
Tomorrow night.
However,
tonight I am in Tampa to say bump,
bump,
bump.
Bob,
good to do.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm going to see the Patriots play at,
uh,
at Joe Robbie Stadium.
Whatever the fuck they call it up here.
Um,
Donovan Smith.
Fucking memorial stadium.
I don't want you to call it Tampa.
The fucking,
okay.
Pirates of the Caribbean stadium.
What the fuck is the name of it?
It actually has a regular name.
The fuck is Tampa Goddamn fucking Tampa football stadium.
I know it.
I know this fucking name.
But anyways,
this is the last one I have to go to
here.
We got football stadium.
Come on,
come on.
What's it?
Raymond James Raymond James Stadium.
Um,
this is the last of the 32 professional football teams that I need to see a home
game of.
Uh,
this will be the 34th one that I've been to cause I went to Saint Louis Rams and
also the San Diego chargers.
And then they both moved to La and I went to those games because I guess I have
a problem.
Um,
so I'm looking for,
this is going to be fucking awesome.
Thursday night football,
they're going to get out there and they're under roos wearing all the same
colored fucking clothes.
Ultra patriots go with blue rather than read.
MMM.
The Red on red,
Jesus Christ.
It's just,
I don't know,
somebody is going to have to wear it because I think that,
uh,
but maybe Tampa would go with the gray.
I don't know guys.
I think that they should have a fashion runway to start it.
Um,
so of course the big,
the big question you gotta ask,
I'm,
you know,
I'm always into fucking a,
I'm a cunt.
You know what I mean?
So I don't give a fuck about the wide receivers.
I don't give a shit about your quarterback.
She run it back.
What's going on at the offensive line?
Christ's sake.
If he can't defend your fucking quarterback and you can't fucking blow up and
some God damn holes,
you're not going to make any passes of running again.
I'll tell you right now,
you're not going to buy any yard in this fucking week.
I gotta be quiet because this thing is everyone's so loud here.
Um,
so what does it come down to?
The the fucking diva.
The offensive line.
All right.
They'll rock star the one that makes all the fucking money.
Nobody cares about the fucking guards.
Nobody gives a shit about the center.
Nobody gives a fuck about the right tackle.
It's all about the left tackle in the NFL,
protecting the blind side.
Unless she have a lefty.
Unless you have a lefty,
how many left the NFL fucking quarterbacks are there and how pissed as the left
tackle on that fucking line.
You know,
he finally gets his name.
Shout it out.
The next soldier,
right.
Does that,
he say's themes.
Naked soldier.
He's only been with us for fucking ever.
They just never say his name because he rarely fucks up.
Donovan Smith.
Let's give me my new thing.
No one,
the left tackles no one who's making the money up there on the offensive line.
So according to the scouting report,
Donovan Smith,
a Penn State guy,
Penn state guys,
always,
always solid football players.
Just a great program up there when they're not up there touching kids,
they just do wonderful things.
Wonderful God damn things you know,
and then not snap and towels and unsuspecting eight year olds.
Sorry Penn State,
you fucking earned it.
All right.
And you know good and God damn well,
despite what happened up there,
you still want to see the Joe Pa statute come back.
And what does that,
what does that say about you?
Um,
what does that say about statues?
What is,
you know,
what I do love about,
Penn state and it's not the molestation of children.
What I love,
you're going to get it.
This,
I'm going to give the Catholic Church Shit.
I got to give it to you too.
You know what I mean?
Penn state football program was like the Catholic Church fucking slide.
Like the Catholic church is like the Big Burger with the bacon on it when it
comes to fucking rape and kids and uh,
but you know,
just sheer number,
you know,
if you looked at,
at,
at molested kids,
like you were counting calories,
all right?
They're definitely that Wendy's triple cheeseburger,
the Catholic churches where Penn state is just,
it's,
you know,
little sliders.
I'm just going to have,
I'm just going to nibble.
I told my thumb,
I've been doing so great at the gym.
I could cheat tonight,
but I'm,
Chet is gonna fucking nimble.
Um,
but I do love about the Penn state.
I realized it wasn't everybody up there who was raping children.
Okay.
Now that's when you know,
you've,
I know that's when you know your program is in trouble.
When in order to defend it,
you have to say,
hey,
not everybody was up there.
Rape and kids bump,
Blah Blah.
Doodoo dude.
All right.
I just liked that they have the basic simple fucking uniforms.
Okay.
Cause I gotta be honest with you,
the first time I saw those Oregon ducks,
those crazy uniforms,
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And then after a while I kind of liked them like,
Eh,
you know,
it's kind of cool,
whatever.
But now it's just become a fucking fashion show.
And there's a bunch of Shitty fucking football programs out there.
You know what I'm talking about?
University of Illinois,
where the fuck do you get off with that disco ball in your head?
Like you've ever been sniffed a big 10 championship since we were even in
fucking Vietnam.
Let's look that up right now.
Let's look that up right fucking now.
When was the last time that basketball school,
when a big time.
Big 10 champs t championship.
I can't fucking talk.
All right.
University of,
okay.
Indiana tech.
Was I saying Illinois?
Sorry,
Indiana.
Um,
okay.
Last big 10 football.
I guarantee you we were in covered covered wagons here.
Football Championship.
I guarantee you the starting 11 were all white guys.
Indiana.
Hoosier football.
Here we go.
They thought it'd be a quick Wikipedia page.
All right.
Um,
why am I picking on these guys are location,
conference,
bowl,
record three and eight conference titles too.
They won one in 1945.
Bob At OPA.
[inaudible] we won the war.
Let's all make kids.
Let's all cure diseases.
Then we'll have a bunch of hurricanes cause with their own wind,
plastic in the ocean.
Um,
1967,
because
I will not seek,
nor will I accept a second term as your prayer.
Who the fuck does Lbj singing?
Sunshiny Your Life,
Huh?
Who should be is more importantly probably the question.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm going to the fucking game tonight.
Uh,
look for Jamison Winston to have a career day because our defense is like the
make a wish foundation opposing quarterback.
What is your dream?
Gee,
I've always wanted to throw for 400 yards.
No problem.
Not only are we going to make that happen,
we're going to do it in the first half.
[inaudible] Gudu Gudu Gudu alright,
go fuck yourself now.
I just trashed my own team before you guys all get all butthurt no fucking pun
intended.
All right about me.
Making Fun of your God damn team.
Donovan Smith is the left tackle.
Okay
for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
He is from Penn state.
He is evidently according to the one scouting report that I looked up,
has yet to live up to his potential
quick footed,
very athletic for his size,
has great hands,
but has yet to live up to his potential.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but if he is,
then I am going to,
I want to nominate him for the delight.
Howard,
not Dwight.
Dwight white people.
Dwight Howard,
not white.
Dwight Black Dwight Dwight.
All right,
Howard.
Given the Dwight Howard award,
every time you look at Dwight Howard,
you gotta be thinking,
what the fuck is wrong with that guy?
That guy is like,
he's like a fucking superhero.
He's so God damn big.
It's so strong.
It's like,
why don't you just steal one move from Kevin Mchale to from a Kima Lodge one and
just dominate the fucking league.
I don't know what he does all day.
He looks like he does curls and goes to the barber shop.
Tear is always perfect.
He's always fucking shredded,
but he just stick.
There's no fire in the man's game.
Okay.
You know,
you know when you go and you play pickup hoop,
right?
Like I've done that and this decade I have,
I can't remember last time you play pickup,
who put the fucking worst was,
well,
if you got that little fella garden,
you on defense.
You know what I mean?
And you'd fuck the fucking guy was just all over you.
Is fucking junk was right on your leg.
It's like I get it.
I get it.
You're taking this seriously.
When you get the fuck off me just d and you're up full court fucking press.
It's like,
buddy,
we're just out here to fucking burn off some calories.
Okay.
You know,
we all ate a Caesar Salad then just figure it out.
The dressing.
It was like eating a fucking burger.
Can you just,
can you let me just run to the fucking half court line?
MMM.
Anyways,
so,
uh,
yeah,
I don't know what the fuck is going on with our defense.
Um,
I have no idea.
As I mentioned,
as I mentioned on our last podcast are safeties and,
and in our corner,
one of our corners,
they've all played with each other for fucking years and the only,
yeah,
no guys is Stefan Gilmore and I,
I can't imagine that the entire defense is going to shit because of one fucking
quarterback.
I'll have to watch tonight sitting up high.
What does he play?
Does he play on the right side of the defense?
I don't know.
All I know is Tampa doesn't have any fucking sacks for the sheer,
I kept looking up.
There's no fucking way.
They have no sex went into October.
They have no sex.
Are they protesting?
Um,
I dunno what violence against fucking white quarterbacks.
You never know what the NFL,
it's always about a co because they finally got rid of the pink.
Now it's domestic violence awareness month as if nobody aware that there was
domestic violence.
You know,
I'll tell you what's fucked up is anytime professional football player beats his
wife,
it becomes national fucking news.
Okay.
Yet a plumber can slap his wife around through a fucking 25 30 year marriage.
And you're never going to hear about it on ESPN or you know,
you are not.
And what are they going to do?
They're going to create this false fucking image that athletes are the only ones
out there who occasionally flip out when there's ranch dressing rather than blue
cheese for their buffalo wings.
Right?
Okay.
God forbid if an athlete does something,
it's all over the fucking news.
But if an account accountant fucking starts shaking his wife a little bit too
much in an Applebee's,
you know,
does ESPN,
do they cover that?
Does the NFL suspend that account?
No,
they do not.
So I want to ask you,
how much does ESPN,
how much does he end up felt truly care until they start covering the domestic
violence?
Yeah.
Done by all men comedians too.
I'll tell you right now,
I put my wife in a triangle right before I went on the road.
Okay.
I said,
this house is going to be quick when I get home.
Um,
this isn't a funny topic that should not be joked about.
I'm now going to fucking grandstand about it as I wear clothes that were made in
a sweatshop.
Cause I care.
I got my wife with a good one yesterday.
Um,
I text her,
uh,
I texted her,
hey,
when I get back to town,
I'm going to take you to Barney's,
you know,
it's his fancy clothing place,
right?
That I never heard about it until there was a woman in my life.
And that is,
that is a 100% truth.
And then they turn around and they wonder why every once in a while they catch
it back camp.
We're taking callers.
Um,
I uh,
yeah,
it's a fancy place.
This clothing store called Barneys.
So I text her,
you know,
cause now that I have the little one,
my little bull bear,
um,
the level of guilt that I have when I go on the fucking road.
I mean,
I got to ask other parents,
like,
when do you hit the ceiling of the love that you feel for your kid?
It's like every day.
It just,
it just keeps,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
uh,
it's like Wah,
you know,
I don't watch game of Thrones,
but like every year when the new season comes out,
like the fucking excitement gets higher.
And I always think,
well,
at some point it's got to level off and it's not happening.
So like you've never had a kid coming home to your kid is the same level of
excitement of these nerds on Twitter when a new season of game of Thrones comes
up.
Okay.
The same falsetto excitement goes into your voice.
It's unbelievable.
Um,
so I have a tremendous amount of guilt when I leave now,
but I mean,
everybody's got to eat.
So I gotta you know,
I mean,
a plumber keeps plumbing is sinks,
right?
Um,
so,
um,
okay,
what the fuck was my point
coming home?
Oh yeah.
So I have all this guilt.
So,
um,
I texted me,
I said,
Hey Neil,
when I get home,
when I get back,
I'm taking it to Barney's.
And she goes,
she's like,
oh my God.
Exclamation at some point.
She goes,
yeah,
really?
And then I text back.
Beanery
the good one.
She's such a hot shit.
She fucking laughed her off.
Barney's beanery by the way,
is a a isn't,
it isn't a an La eatery out here where they give you a completely irresponsible
level of food when you go in there irresponsible.
If you care about human life,
I'll heroic portion of food if you're truly informed and concerned about the
environmental issues that are about to hit us.
Last week I was writing for hurricane monthly
and if you look up that article recently,
I want a doctorate at uh,
at Massasoit community college and now I feel,
I know.
Thanks.
So of course now I am going to have people refer to me as a doctor for the rest
of my life.
Like bill Cosby.
Didn't bill Cosby always do that doctor bill Cosby.
It's like,
dude,
you got an honorary degree.
Unless I'm out of my fucking mind,
I shouldn't have said his name.
Speaking of Penn State,
uh Oh Geez.
It's spelled Jesus.
Jesus.
She,
everybody's just getting trashed on this one.
Well,
you know what,
I'm a little grumpy.
Okay.
I took a fucking red on.
You know,
it's funny,
I'm sitting there saying I miss my kid.
But I'm still a selfish and came out here a day early to go to a football game
to,
to fucking,
well,
you know what?
I still have doubt my hobbies.
I'm a big believer in that.
You gotta be a little selfish still as a dead.
All right bill,
Talk Yourself off the guilt ledge.
Give yourself the free fucking pass here.
No,
you still have to have you fucking hobby.
Um,
you know something to look forward to when the,
when your kid,
you're fucking bundle of joy finally falls asleep.
You know what I mean?
Everybody goes,
Hey,
when your kid sleeps you sleep.
You know what I say?
I say fuck that.
You go out in the garage,
you play a couple of pair of doodles.
All right?
You go on the Internet and you learn how to play crazy train.
That's what you do,
okay?
You don't sleep is for sleep is for liberals that care about other air quote
care about other people.
Okay.
If you look at conservative people,
those people never sleep,
okay?
Cause they don't like anybody and they just sit there staring out their fucking
window.
Even if they have a conservative next door neighbor,
they do not trust them.
Okay.
Cause they,
they are,
they are type a can you be a type a liberal?
Okay.
I don't know what type B is.
Type A is fucking annoying.
You know what I mean?
That's basically what it is.
Tape is the kind of person that needs a fucking entourage,
right?
Type A's,
the kind of person that goes through the security line at the airport.
Right.
And when he gets to the other side,
takes all his fucking shit out and doesn't fucking get his been out of the
fucking way.
He doesn't give a shit.
It's all about him.
You know,
if you broke,
if you did like a fucking,
uh,
an airport security combine,
okay.
And you watched me go through,
rather than running the 40 yard deaths,
it's you getting,
you're getting ready to get your all your shit off and you're fucking laptop
out.
Okay.
I would test off the fucking charts.
Of course.
I'll always be the slow fucking white dude that I am,
but when I get to the other fucking side,
all right.
When I get to the underside after I've been fucking slowly cooked in that little
microwave that they sticky and what she know something I've actually just given
it to at this point,
if they want to slowly kill me,
I say good.
I say good for them.
You know,
why?
Because we're overpopulated and who am I to say that I should still be here?
Led the lizard people fucking kill everybody and start over again with the
robots were taken costs.
Um,
so I get through when I get on the other side,
that's when Bill Bella checks going to draft me when everybody else looks past
me.
Okay.
With my Bunker Hill community college educational background,
just given all kinds of community colleges shouts out from Massachusetts shout
outs this week.
Um,
this Thursday,
um,
this is when
bill Bellacheck would finally smiled.
Like the Grinch at the end of the Grinch stole Christmas is when he saw me
fucking not only get my fucking bins,
I grab everybody else's bins
and Mumble,
come on people loud enough for people to hear,
but not loud enough for anyone to address me.
Right.
And he sees that I lead by example.
Yeah.
The,
the level of judging that I do when I go to the fucking airport security line,
and when you fucking take your shit out of the Bin and you just fucking leave it
there,
I'm like,
you are a selfish fucking cunt.
You get,
you're a terrible mother.
You're a terrible father.
You're a terrible fucking person.
Okay.
And if I was as blessed is that fat fuck in North Korea to be running everything
in stealing all the ham,
keeping it all for myself,
right?
He gets a haircut every day.
That's selfish.
Fuck.
Okay.
Is All these people are fucking starving probably because of the economic stank
shanks sanctions that the free world has placed upon him.
And he's like,
fuck that.
I'm the leader.
I get all the pork chops.
I need to stay clear between my big butcher block fucking head.
All right?
I need to stay clear to know when it is,
when it's time,
because we're dealing with the Lord.
I want to how scared they are of Trump.
It's just kind of fun.
This is like we're matching crazy homeless guy to crazy homeless guy.
Remember they had those things.
Bum fights.
That's what's going on at the fucking political level.
This is a bum fight.
All right.
Don't let the uniform in the fucking suit,
which a lot of people will say is a uniform.
Okay?
A lot of people in the liberal arts major of a college will say that it is,
that it is a uniform,
that it is a boys' club,
that it is a system that needs to be shut down and they'll say this as they
don't wear a fucking Bra.
What the tits swinging too and fucking fro as if they're making a statement.
I love that thing that women want to do,
like the people,
the women that are rejecting bras.
It's just this is some sort of restricted thing.
It's like,
Hey,
we were doing you a favor.
We already stare your Teddy's enough.
If you want to walk around with your nipple sticking out of your fucking shirt,
if you ever think that that's going to get fucking old on our side of the fence,
I say you remove your bronze and your room,
you remove them.
Now,
um,
you know,
I should do more podcasts with 50 foot ceilings.
I think my ego,
just that there's finally enough space in a room for my fucking head.
I'm excited.
I'm going to a football game tonight.
My last one,
my last one that I have to go to and I've been to all the baseball,
all of the football.
Who the fuck can say that?
You think I'm going to stop there?
I'm not.
I'm going to see all the hockey and all the basketball.
You think I'm going to stop there?
I'm not.
Yeah,
I went to the Daytona 500 I'm going to Talladega next year.
I've been to the Kentucky Derby.
I don't give it this.
I'm doing the fucking road.
I'm going to every bread and circus puts your fucking thoughts on hold sporting
event that this great nation has.
And when I'm done here,
I'm going overseas.
Okay.
Can you think I'm eating?
You do think I'm fucking above going to a cricket match?
Arguably the greatest drinking game ever,
ever created.
If you go to a traditional one,
it takes a fucking a week to play.
You can literally go on a week long fucking bender and your wife can't say
anything.
It's like what honey?
I told you I was going to the game.
Am Am I allowed to have a little bit of fun life?
Um,
NHL starts tonight.
Bump up.
Um,
yeah,
and I believe I heard through the grapevine that ESPN guts the Formula One
contract for next year.
So Espn,
could you do me a favor?
Can you please not apply?
You're progressive formula,
whatever the fuck it is that you're doing.
I know you're taking on water over there because everybody's watching sports on
the APP,
but can you please,
can you please keep Formula One,
the international gem that it is.
Can you please not replace everybody and get a bunch of Americans in there,
right.
One from each race like they do on the MTV real world.
And then you have a woman running it,
whatever it is.
And then in the end,
you feel good about yourselves before you go back to your white,
your whites only gated community.
I'm fucking with you.
I don't give a shit.
Just,
I don't give a fuck if it's all women.
I don't give a fuck if everybody's sweat healing helion.
However you said,
can you just get somebody out there that knows what the fuck they're talking
about and can deliver their points without screaming movie quotes?
Okay.
Can you do that?
Can you do that without going around the horn and having some fucking goddamn
air raid siren going off for fucking every 20 minutes,
that fucking shelf?
Anybody can explain to me how points are earned in lost on that show.
I swear to God,
you should be running this nation.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
do you think why you guys,
listen,
this is just the ramblings of a crabby old man.
I'll tell you,
you know something that I don't understand.
I don't understand why the Internet every fucking day has to tell me that this
is the greatest fucking thing that I'm ever going to see.
And I also don't understand why I'm so fucking stupid.
Like a moth flying towards a fucking bright light in the middle of the night.
I always click on it and it,
oh,
it always underwhelms me
like the Shannon Sharpe thing this week.
What the fuck was so fucking amazing about that?
Yeah,
I'm on that.
And mild in that hand dog and everybody,
like the one that I clicked on,
was it,
it was at this moment that Shannon Sharpe became the president of the United
States.
He's putting a cheap cigar in his mouth,
making a reference to the boozy lakes.
Okay.
That's the greatest thing that ever happened.
I mean,
I,
I guess,
I don't know.
You're telling me,
you telling me like that that's better than then
when Ossie played live
on that fucking TV show,
looks like a basic cable show and he came out with a tracksuit that said Ozzie
it in case he forgot what his fucking name was and he had Rudy Sarillo on base.
Randy Rhodes on guitar and fucking Tommy Aldridge on drums.
And you see,
you see like Ozzy literally turning around in awe of his own fucking band.
Get telling me,
yeah,
dead.
A guy taking a Dutch master and he would be one thing if he had the fucking
bottle of booze right there.
You know what it is,
Bill.
It's just young people having fun and you're taking it literally and you know
what you're doing.
You're doing,
when you said you always weren't going to do,
which is you,
you were,
you were not going to hang around young people.
You,
you knew that your time had come and gone and you were going to let them have
their fucking fun.
You know what?
So I apologize.
You guys are absolutely right.
That was the greatest thing that ever happened.
And he should be the next wall.
I mean,
the next leader.
That'd be actually a great fucking thing.
If you had him as leader and then he was communicating with that guy in North
Korea,
then the guy in North Korea could not get mad because he could not understand
what the fuck Shan is sharps talking about.
Do you remember in World War II when we had like native Americans speaking and
uh,
communicate and shit and the Japanese couldn't crack it?
Yeah.
Shannon Sharpe is the modern day version of that.
I'll never understand it.
I don't know why.
Just because I could understand every fucking word that he said is a pro.
He was fucking hilarious,
you know,
sending the Patriot missiles and all that.
The second he became a commentator,
I dunno what happened.
Um,
all right,
Luke Craig.
So he stuck his tongue in a fucking beehive.
All right,
Luke crate be the envy.
Gimme the Lou.
Be The envy of your friends and get 100% exclusive products at [inaudible] dot
com slash burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off on any new subscriptions.
The nerve of me saying that Shannon is difficult to understand.
What I can't even fucking read out loud.
October's Lou crepe thing is mythical loot crate offers an epic range of pop
culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical Fashionista,
then try loot where all of this shit's going to edit an ocean someday in,
in at least develop a tropical storm monthly wearables and accessories with cold
classics and your favorite franchises if you want to get fancy.
Yeah.
Do you want to get a bigger box with even bigger loop with Lou crate DX?
Uh,
you hear the stories,
the whispers of creatures and beings beyond your imagination.
I go every time.
I think it's a phrase,
it's a fucking sentence.
I don't even know what I'm saying here.
You hear the stories,
the whispers of creatures and beings beyond imagination.
Okay?
You hear that in the trunk,
but you hear that in your head.
Something's going on because I fucked this read up every time and they continue
to advertise with me.
So that must mean that I have a bunch of people are into this shit.
Join us as we peer into the shadows and look into the other realms for October's
truly mythical collection.
Okay.
Get unreal items from marvel,
Ghostbusters,
stranger things and Buffy the vampire slayer.
One lucky subscriber will also,
when a mega crate of seriously epic proportions,
you have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific time to subscribe and receive that
month's crate.
And when the cutoff happens that it,
that's it.
It's all go to Luke,
Luke [inaudible] dot com slash burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off on any
new subscription today.
I have no idea.
I mean they could,
they could literally write that in Spanish and I would fucking understand it
just as much as what I just said.
Their thought fee.
Everybody.
Me,
how everyone at some point has wished they could have have beer,
wine or liquor delivered.
Oh,
absolutely.
APPS fucking Luli we have,
well,
someone finally decided to do something about it.
I love it.
And I love the John Wade vibe of this copy.
MMM.
Okay.
Next please mention all of the talking points below.
Well just write them and I'll read them.
Introducing thought fee.
The alcohol delivery APP,
saucy delivers your favorite wine,
beer and liquor,
right to your door on demand.
You know,
I watched this fucking twilight zone.
MMM.
The twilight zone of,
what's it called?
16 millimeter prison or whatever.
And it was about this aging ingenue.
She used to be this big star in the 1930s and she couldn't handle the fact that
she wasn't young anymore.
So she just,
she just sat in her mansion in this dark room watching all of her old movies,
drinking booze.
And as I watched it,
I was like,
I would love to fucking do that.
What'd you just love to take a decade off from your life?
They can just watch old home movies of back when you were sober.
You know,
it could get out of bed without making noises and shit.
Right.
And just sit there and you know,
there is something to be said about drinking yourself to death.
Okay.
You know,
as long as she can walk around like a nice fancy evening gown with a train like
she had,
you know,
just be all [inaudible].
All right,
we're back to the copy.
Um,
now if you live in Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego or Sacramento,
you're thought the order will arrive at your door in 30 minutes or less.
Ready to drink for the rest of us thought the will deliver beer,
wine,
and liquor to your door in two days or less.
Nationwide.
There are no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you,
if you've got the saucy APP,
you've got a fully stocked bar on your phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download the saucy app and enter the Promo Code Burr.
That's the saucy APP,
spelledF ,
a u s e y and enter Promo Code Burr for $15 off.
Get the saucy app today and use Promo Code Berg.
Oh Shit.
No.
Cousy at five o club looking good.
Doesn't need to cost a fortune five folk is revolutionizing the way men shop at
five four club.
I've never had copy that says it's fucking name more than these people.
They've found a way to make looking great,
uh,
great looking clothes,
affordable for everyone.
Five four club also understands that your time is extremely valuable.
Why wasted at the mall or wandering around stores when he can sit at home and
have saucy delivery.
Your bows,
you can order that evening gown with the train with fat,
low fat mother fucker.
Each month they send you a curated box at two to three items that are handpicked
to match the current season and your style.
Five four club partners.
What defense you run into three.
Four?
No,
the fo five o with two fucking safeties is that the cover to um,
partners with a cutting edge designs and brands.
So you'll get the same quality as top designer clothes for way less.
They've been helping men with fashion for over 15 years and shipped a 100,000
men every month.
Chris Paul and Mark Walberg use five folk club and five pho is featuring,
featuring and Gq vice and in style among other applications.
This is like a fucking actor or an athlete that's completely lost their mind and
speaks about themselves in the third person.
This is fucking ridiculous.
There's still another half a paragraph.
Let's count how many times they say that their name again.
They know what they're doing.
So if you don't,
that's okay.
Five Oh,
that's one club will help you build your wardrobe one month at a time because
when you look good,
you feel good.
It's a fact of life.
It's also a cliche.
You don't need to say that you get $120 worth of clothes for just $60 a month.
That's half off.
You can pause or cancel anytime,
no commitments.
And as a five four club,
that's two member,
you receive up to 50% of off items in their online shop and access to exclusive
members only,
not the jacket items.
Free Shipping,
it's size
exchanges.
Sorry,
go to five,
four club,
three Europe,
dotcom right now and enter Promo code and they'll give you 50% off your first
month's package plus a free pair of sunglasses.
That's 50% off your first package at five folk clubs,
spelled F I e f o u r.com.
That's four times plus spelling.
That's five Promo Coper five four club.
That's five promocode Berg.
All right,
frame bridge,
everybody.
Thank God this is the last one.
Frame Bridge.
Frame Bridge is the easiest way to custom your weighted custom frame,
your favorite art and photos without ever leaving your house.
You know,
there's a fine line between being that person that has in their life and then
like you have way too many fucking photos on your fucking wall and it's like,
is this person stalking somebody?
You know what I mean?
So when you use frame bridge,
make sure there's enough up there of your dog and you know,
whatever fucking landscapes or some shit don't have like 58 of just family
members.
All right,
that's fucking weird.
Your family members are not famous.
Nobody gives a shit.
Uh,
with our simple online ordering process,
you can order a fully customized piece in minutes.
Here's how,
now if you're me,
take me a fucking hour.
Here's how it works.
Go to Frame bridge.com upload your photo from your computer or directly from an
Instagram feed,
and if it's silly enough,
we'll share it with the rest of the Internet and it'll become a meme and you'll
never get to leave your house again.
Then you can go to saucy order your fucking booze and five four club to order
your new pajamas.
Look at that,
that's called,
that's called an advertising callback.
Or if you have the physical item,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photo online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get help from their talented designer,
the expert team at frame bridge or custom frame your item and 10 days,
not weeks or month to deliver your finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang the best part instead of hundreds,
you pay at a framing store.
Their prices start at $39 all shipping is free.
My,
uh,
plus my listeners get 15% off their first order of frame,
bridge.com when they use my code.
Burr,
give your personal experience using frame,
bridge.com the site,
the ease of order,
how your piece turned out and how easy and affordable it was.
Get started today.
Framing your photos are our,
go to [inaudible] dot com and use the Promo code [inaudible].
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order frame.
bridge.com/birth uh oh frame bridge.com code [inaudible].
That's what it,
it's not slash bar code bar.
You know first he's fucking hilarious.
Fucking hilarious.
Oh,
like,
oh,
he's right.
My fault.
He okay.
I thought he was getting in and fucking six o'clock in the h and the game was at
fucking seven.
I was like,
you're going to go straight to the game.
All right.
Uh,
hang on a second.
My fault.
I thought the game was at seven.
Okay.
All right.
Now I got him all fucking nervous.
All right,
that's it.
Oh good.
I've got time to do my first elliptical.
Now that I fucking,
oh,
did I tell you guys,
I got my first Mri,
I got one on my shoulder and then I got one on my calf to make sure I don't have
any blood clots from whatever the fuck I did to my leg.
You know what I mean?
They didn't want to stroke out while I was doing fucking jumping jacks.
Um,
so anyways,
Jesus Christ,
it's fucking hilarious.
She go in there and sometimes they let you use headphones from what I've heard.
But my place that I went to,
which by the way was fucking hilarious.
I walk and the chick behind the desk is all tatted up and I'm like,
like to the point,
it's like,
do you play in a band?
If you don't,
you should.
She look like a rock star,
but she's wearing scrubs.
You know,
that should have been my first red flag.
Like what kind of fucking medical places this,
I mean,
she was cool as shit,
but I'm just saying,
you know,
so then I go down there and when I get out it's cash only.
The second business is cash only,
and there's not a bunch of of Italians running it.
I'm like,
all right,
what the fuck is going on here?
There's something about Italians cash only.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
it's like,
oh,
that piece of America that's now gone.
It's actually quite,
but everybody else,
I'm like,
what kind of fucking kind of shit is going on here?
Um,
all right,
so that's the podcast here.
Oh,
look at that and give you 45 minutes on a Thursday.
Um,
that's it.
Oh,
Billy.
No Fun.
49 days.
No booze,
no fucking Busan.
MMM.
Oh Geez.
I gotta take this call.
All right,
I'll have a great weekend and I'll,
uh,
I'll talk to you on Monday then.
She
was
with dominion,
Indiana boys on in Indiana.
The way was more than I was damn close.
Dot.
You said a big baby,
but got to keep moving on.
Yes.
Um,
wife's family.
The secret upstairs.
All right.
Hey,
bill loved the podcast and all the bullshit.
So I've been dating this lady who I completely love,
can't get enough for her.
We've been going out for a solid two years now.
Good for you.
There is always been a rule at her house.
She lives with their parents because she's in a program in order to become a vet
tech.
So money's tight for her that I am not allowed to go upstairs ever.
All right.
Being a guy,
I have no with this.
Uh,
I'll bender over the pool table and her,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
where this,
this took a left turn.
I'll bend her over the pool table.
Her father built because fuck it.
If you try to stop me from banging her in the bed,
I'll just find another way.
All right.
To what?
What did that have to do with what you're talking about?
You got me all interested in.
Why can't you go upstairs?
Like there's this big mystery.
Now all of a sudden you're like,
well fine,
I'll vendor over the fucking hot water heater downstairs.
He can't stop me.
All right.
Hi.
I'm hoping you're going to get back on track here.
That was like a weird beat,
a B story.
Um,
he goes,
so I finally get annoyed at this whole no upstairs policy and decide to do a
little investigating.
Well,
aren't you just a nosy little cunt?
Did you finally get annoyed of the rules of a house that isn't yours?
You know what,
sir?
So this far into your email,
I don't like you.
I don't like that whole shit.
We deal.
You haven't.
You're disrespecting her father and Santa.
I'm going to fuck your daughter over the pool table that you built.
All right.
That's supposed to be internal monologue.
You're not supposed to share that with others
anyways.
No one in the house at this point,
by the way.
Oh,
there's no one in the house.
Why can't you guys help me out?
You know I suck at reading.
He,
okay.
There's no one in the house at this point,
by the way.
I work third shift,
so they leave me the fuck alone between 8:00 AM to 3:00 PM.
I went upstage upstairs and I find a garbage in the hallway.
Every room is filled with junk and there's only one way to enter it.
This is every room,
her parent's room,
hers,
the office.
It's all a complete nightmare just waiting for Tlc to show up.
I'm now giving you that.
How can I approach this ordeal with her?
I love her to death and she may be moving in with me sometime between the next
few months.
This shit is not gonna fly with me,
but I know that if a resident gets that bad,
that there is something wrong with them.
Mentally.
She has always been messy.
But then again,
I'm a fucking cop who doesn't have time to clean up my place.
So maybe this is the calm before the storm with this chick.
Um,
yeah,
that's really fucked up now.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
you know something,
you're already broke the seal.
This is what I would do.
This is so fucking creepy
if you,
if you really want to make a go with this girl,
I guess.
I guess I would go back up there again
and I go into her room and just have a look around and look like if that's some
parents shit or if that's her shit.
You know what I mean?
Um,
and if it's her shit,
I would be,
uh,
at Jesus is fucking brutal.
The things you don't,
what the big thing is,
is the fact that the downstairs is immaculate.
So they're there.
They're only halfway down the rabbit hole.
Um,
I dunno dude.
You know what?
This is your tree.
You're fucking sitting in it.
I don't that there's no way to bring up that you went upstairs without just
saying I went upstairs.
What are you going to say?
Well,
the bath the eyes is what year is what you do.
This is what you do.
You're clog up the bathroom downstairs.
All right.
Okay.
Just clog up the fucking toilet downstairs.
I don't know how you'd do it,
but just clog that fucker up.
Okay.
And then just say I had to take a shit.
I,
it was nowhere else to go.
I had to do it right.
And then you just say you went upstairs,
saw what the fuck it was,
and then you went back downstairs.
All right.
So that's what you do,
clog up the toilet and just blame it on the fact that you had to take your shit.
Why am I helping you with this lie?
And it was funny to me.
Who gives a fuck?
There you go.
And that's what you do and then address it all right.
Or You just man up and just say,
listen,
all right,
the curiosity,
this is,
this is the man's way of doing it.
That's,
that's the bitch way of doing it.
So of course I know how to do that way.
The man just sits down and says,
listen,
I
was fucking weird me out that I could never go upstairs.
I just wanted to top of stairs and I looked to see what the fucking big deal
was,
you know,
like was it made out of gold that you got a sex slave up there?
You know,
there's some dead body.
What the fuck's going on up there?
And uh,
yeah,
that type of shit.
You know,
that's your world.
That's your life.
But uh,
that's not going to happen.
If we have a move in together,
all right,
then she's going to give it,
I can't believe that she went upstairs way and I told you not to,
you just broken the trust.
And,
and they'd be like,
all right,
and let her just do it.
Let her get all of that out.
And then you go,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
What about you?
Okay,
so I just broke the trust.
But you know,
you're the one,
you're kind of,
you had this giant secret,
so you got secrets.
So you kind of fuck with the trust first,
you know,
do you know there's a dead cat up there?
Do you understand that?
Does it fucking dead cat up there?
So I dunno dude,
do one thing or another.
You can do the pussy thing and do the toilet clogged up thing.
I gave you two options there,
sir.
The pussy bitch way or just be a fucking man.
Just take her out,
set it down and just say,
listen,
I got,
I gotta tell you something.
All right.
Uh,
I'm feel ashamed that I did this,
but my curiosity got the best of me and I went to the top of stairs and I just
peeked to see what the big deal was with the upstairs.
Uh,
and you know,
then she'll probably start running away.
But you know,
women,
they don't know how to run.
Most of them.
Women can either run like a fucking track star or they just rent.
They run like it's,
they run like toddlers.
Okay.
You know,
so many of them,
I swear to God,
I'm not saying you don't see the,
an uncoordinated guide jog and every once in a while,
but we,
you know,
we play sports.
We know how to run you guys.
I don't know what you'd do.
You sit around plotting hmm.
Making fucking rumors about each other.
Jesus bill.
Well,
you know why it took a while this week,
didn't it?
43 minutes in before I,
they said some ignorant shit about women.
I'm getting better.
I had to get a nice clean half hour there.
Um,
so when she runs away from you like a,
you know,
somebody blew out her knee.
Yeah.
You'll just sort of jog behind her until she gets tired.
Um,
or just wait til she's wearing high heels until you tell her that,
that gives you an even better chance,
you know?
And she's screaming,
screaming and boohooing and crying and all that.
You know,
you just walked behind it with the hands out,
you know,
looking at other people like you know,
you,
you know,
you'd do that classic,
this isn't my fault shit that that body language to other people,
which is basically you put your hands,
you know,
basically parallel to your shoulders straight out like that,
like you're going to shrug like uh,
you know,
I dunno,
you haven't liked that.
And then after you do that,
then you bring them together in front of you,
motioning at her,
you know,
like a,
it,
you bring it back out again having it Dan,
we just,
she's,
she's just,
and I dunno.
Yeah,
right.
Just back and forth
and then you just say,
well we know something.
And as much as she gives you shit,
just be like,
you know what?
I'm glad I looked.
I'm glad I looked who was up.
I didn't look,
I wouldn't,
you know,
we got to talk about this.
I'm willing to help you through this and everything,
but I can tell you right now,
if you think you're going to move in with me and start doing that stuff,
there's going to be a mountain of shit getting thrown out every fucking week.
All right?
So there you go,
sir.
That is my advice.
That is my advice to your fucking ass.
Good luck to Ya.
All right.
Never slowed down.
Jot is grueling from Todd going down.
Tired of math,
John,
this town.
Oh my man.
That body dress.
Same as cop.
Cause the case.
Okay.
Fuck.
Was I going to talk about the sea?
Oh,
guess what I did this week.
freckled face bill.
Guess what I did,
you know,
a year ago I wrote a fucking motorcycle or whatever.
I went dirt bike riding.
I actually took a motorcycle safety course.
It was a,
it was a day and a half and I gotta tell you,
man,
it was fucking a exhilarating and terrifying.
So I actually,
I passed the class somehow.
I don't think I should have.
I was doing my little ute turns.
They had to put my little foot down there.
Uh,
um,
no,
it was a great fucking time.
So basically how it worked was you rode for like four hours and then you had a
class.
MMM.
And I realized how spoiled I am as a fucking human being,
you know,
just having this,
the life that I have where I don't have a boss and I basically do whatever the
fuck I want.
I have not been in a classroom.
MMM.
I just immediately,
I just takes me back to why I chose the route I chose.
I just never liked the classroom situation,
but this,
this was a,
was actually a great time,
but it just immediately had anxiety and I'm like half paying attention and then,
and then in the end they're like,
okay,
now we're going to do the test.
I went right back to when I was like in eighth grade and I got got,
I'm going to fail this.
The guy's like,
no one has ever failed this.
And you're like,
oh,
good pressure pressure.
I'm a moron.
Was sitting there at the table and everybody's fucking finishing.
Before I was like,
there was like,
I dunno,
40 people in the class.
I think I finished 37th as far as completing the test.
MMM.
I know.
It's just 50 questions I got for rob.
It's something like that.
I don't fucking know.
But somehow I passed and um,
okay.
That was funny.
I've never flipped flopped so much in my life on a decision.
I was thinking,
am I going to get a bike?
You should I just get a dark bike?
Should I just know how to do this?
And then,
you know,
I just wanted to learn how to ride a motorcycle.
You know,
I grew up in the 80s.
All right.
I watched a lot of action movies and one of the things that I always was envious
of the Action Heroes Aside from their oiled up fucking eighties lifting weights,
no squats ever bodies,
was,
uh,
the fact that no matter what vehicle they approached,
not only with the keys always in it,
they knew how to drive.
It knew how to drive everything from a dump truck to a fucking helicopter
airplane.
They could sail.
They could fuck it.
Do So,
you know,
it's coming up where you know,
we got to raise the debt ceiling again.
Eventually the wave's going to hit the beach and there's going to be a period
where you could quite possibly be getting chased down the street by an angry
fucking mob is,
is this,
everything goes to shit,
you know?
So at that point it would be nice if you had the ability to,
whatever escape vehicle you meet you ran into,
you could actually just jump in and just be all right with it.
Right.
So Vestus alone fucking uh,
Arnold Schwartzenegger,
Steven Seagal,
Chuck Norris,
they never,
and I challenge you to find anything that they fucking ran up to when any of
those movies that dated,
not a Jetski fucking motor boat,
sailboat,
submarine,
combine helicopter fucking plane with,
with only can land on water.
Those skis or the tires doesn't make a difference.
They could instrument rated they everything,
everything.
They could be on a fucking plane,
a commercial airline,
and somehow kill the person next to him,
put a hat over their face without anybody noticing,
crawl down into where the luggages and then jump off the landing gear and do a
fucking mash at the end of the,
the,
the runway.
They were unstoppable.
So I've added motorcycle.
All right.
I could drive a car stick or regular and now I can drive a motorcycle.
I'm just checking off the list.
I have a day and a half of experience now.
It was actually really fascinating and it made me a better driver and I actually
have a much more appreciation of,
uh,
of this skill it takes to ride a motorcycle.
It's not like a car.
Yeah,
no shit bill now,
but just shit that you wouldn't think like I didn't,
I didn't understand all that went into just going around a turn on a motorcycle
and out.
Not only do you hit the,
do not hit the break,
but if you hit the brake,
you're actually gonna.
You know,
you're going to crash.
You got to judge,
look through the whole turn,
judge.
You speed and then fucking power your way through it.
Um,
pretty intense.
I got not going to lie to you.
I'm not gonna act like I was,
hey,
I got this,
this is easy.
Then we go into the class and like,
has anybody seen it?
And I'm getting excited like wow.
Then I just wrote a bike for four hours.
I've got it up to third gear down shift and this is fucking great.
And then I went into the class and one of the things,
you know,
the group discussion there was like anybody ever see a motorcycle accident or
been in a motorcycle accident?
It's like fucking almost everybody,
or at least half the class puts their hands up and they start telling stories.
And this one guys was like a paramedic and he's going like,
Yay.
You know,
I saw this guy was going like 90 [inaudible] hit a car head on and his heart
came out of his chest.
He had like all these stories and I was sitting there,
I'm like,
okay,
okay.
Like laughing at myself going,
what the fuck am I signing up for here?
This is insane.
Um,
and then like the guy who was teaching the class who looked like he was born on
a motorcycle and was fucking,
you know,
wrote the same way it was,
obviously he's the instructor.
He's fucking great riding bikes.
He even had a story of a couple of months ago.
Yeah.
You know,
I hit some sand and I was like saying,
you know,
I'm going over the fucking handle bars and I'm like,
keep my body relax.
And all I'm thinking in my head is just like,
dude,
you went down,
you went down.
Yeah.
All right.
This guy,
I'm telling you,
it just look like he was just made the ride a fucking,
we just had that I ride a motorcycle look,
as opposed to me,
it looks like some do.
She goes to take a safety course and I'm just thinking this guy went down,
this guy's an EMT talking about people's hearts coming out of their chest.
I'm just like,
what?
This is fucking stupid,
you know?
So,
uh,
okay.
I on,
I don't know where I'm at.
I think I'm just going to maybe just
right on dark is what I'll do.
You can't,
you can't fucking ride a bike out here in la.
You know what it is?
I'm old enough to know it's fucking stupid.
So,
uh,
I think I'm going to,
if I'm going to do it,
I just get like a dirt bike and I put it in the back of my truck,
drive out of the city and all the people texting,
get to where the trail is and then just ride around on dirt and I know all you
going to be like actually moves feet.
Jld Japi north road people,
not piggy Ted,
you need to,
I know I just stand,
there's risk with everything,
but uh,
yeah.
You know,
I dunno.
I think it's a good thing that I waited till I was 45 to learn how to ride a
motorcycle because if I was thinking if I was 21
okay.
And that I would just,
I wouldn't give a shit ass.
I can happen to me and that's not going to happen to me.
Like you get older and by the time you're,
my age,
shit has happened to you or some close friends.
So you kind of like,
yeah,
you know,
that could happen to me.
Kind of like my heart in my chest on this side of my rib cage.
Uh,
but I got to tell you though,
I definitely got the bug and
okay.
It's the most fucking fun.
Okay.
I even by the second day I was actually getting frustrated
because I was thinking like,
I just want to take this out on the street.
I'm sick of speeding up and slowing down.
I just want to drive this fucking thing.
And uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
Don't worry.
I'm not going to go out and do that.
I'm not going to do that dumb shit.
This is exactly what a lot of people do when they,
when they finally get to where they want to be in life,
which is what I feel I am,
you know,
sell tickets as a comic.
Get some acting gigs every once in a while.
You know,
you got a little free time.
What do you do?
You pull a John Denver,
you go out and get a pilot's license yet out you fly some experimental aircraft
and next thing you know they're the news today.
Singer Song Writer.
All right.
So that's definitely the back of my head.
But um,
okay.
I Dunno,
I don't think knee is going to let me get one anyways to be honest with you.
That's probably a good thing.
But you know what she did when she was saying no,
she did the classic thing like why do you want to like,
you know,
have all these toys.
What is it with guys and have you know,
you,
you have your,
and like what do I have?
I go,
I got my truck,
she goes,
you get your guitars and it's like you're upset with me cause I'm enjoying life.
And she's like,
no,
you know,
I think she just doesn't want me to get one.
So she tried to do that stupid argument that the motorcycle was this extension.
Like it's like your Dick,
like you guys like kids between their legs and they have ride this thing down
the street.
It's a psych.
I don't know what the fuck that is about.
Okay.
When I was riding for the last two days,
at no point was I thinking about my deck other than thinking like I hope I don't
fall off and uh,
when I'm going fast enough that I get road rash on my Dick,
that would be the only thing.
Other than that,
I,
you know what,
I wish,
I wish she took the class with me.
You know?
That's what I was actually thinking.
It'd be great if she took the fucking class with me and she would just see how
much fun it is.
It's fun.
Okay.
You know,
I don't know.
Fucking know.
So,
uh,
I got the bug now.
I got the bug and I was looking at motorcycles all last night.
So I was telling her,
I said,
look,
all I want to do,
I'm just going to get like the Honda rebel.
It's a fucking two 50.
It's exactly what I should get when I start out.
If I get something else,
I'll kill myself.
And she starts,
you know,
looking up those stupid Ducati's,
which were cool about up until six months ago.
Now,
every Douche bag out there has him.
Like everybody seems to have one of those fucking things.
So,
you know,
I don't know.
I looked at the new Harley's and I don't like them.
I think they're ugly.
They kind of lost their way.
They at used to look meaner.
So I'm just going to,
if I'm going to get one,
I'm either going to get dark bike or I'm going to get this little fucking two
50.
I think the speedometer only goes up to like 70 or 80.
MMM.
I Dunno.
Tell me,
what do you,
what do you guys think?
And this is,
and this is going to be one of those extreme,
uh,
conversations.
And believe me,
I've heard all the things get a motorcycle.
You might as well buy the coffin to go with it.
It's not a helmet,
it's a brain bucket.
I've heard all of that shit.
Um,
I dunno,
it does seem like a lot of fun,
right?
Uh,
you know,
if I,
if I get one,
I'm going to be one of those douchebags who gets like a little two 50 and I'll
have like all the gear on and be dressed like all Samuelson.
If he ever rode a motorcycle,
flipped completely over,
protected fucking robocop suit on it and I just ride around my neighborhood,
never,
never get out of second gear.
Um,
anyway,
so that's what the fuck I did with my week.
But you know,
it's good to know though,
if I ever get chased by a bunch of people with hatchets down the street and I
happened upon a fucking motorcycle and there's a little key there provided it's
not an old one with the throttles on the other side
or the shift or whatever the fuck it is.
Uh,
I'll be able to,
I'll be able to escape,
you know.
All right,
this bitch on market square,
she's staying in
a hotel room
will be coming soon.
Got to pull it was to go cry when he woke up alone and hit the last number.
Yay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It is the Monday morning podcast for a Monday,
October 5th,
2009.
How the hell are you?
Well that's good.
I'm actually fighting off disease this week.
I'm back here on the east coast and everybody is getting sick and I did a smart
thing.
I actually fucking came home and I felt myself getting sick.
I took some vitamins and I just slept for like fucking 10 hours.
Um,
hence the podcast is a little bit late,
I apologize is always,
but um,
yeah man,
I had a great weekend.
I was out of [inaudible] Stress Factory in New Jersey and I'm starting to feel
it,
man.
I'm starting to get on top of my game.
Um,
regular listeners,
you know,
I'm getting ready to do another special and um,
I've really put my time in with this one.
I did Sweden than I did Boston.
Then I did Philly,
then I did Dallas and now I just did New Brunswick,
New Jersey five weeks in a row.
No,
I had one week off between Sweden and uh,
and Boston.
And uh,
I got to tell you,
man,
there's no substitute for that.
There really isn't.
I don't give a fuck.
You have to go out on the road.
You got to do the shows,
you got to do six shows a weekend and you really have to be like,
I'm really working on this one.
Making sure the set order is right.
And uh,
you know,
cause that's,
that's how you got to do it.
You want to have a memorable,
you don't just want to,
you know,
that's the worst fucking thing you can do,
I think in any,
any party of life.
Work your ass off on something and then just get your reaction of black.
And I mean,
it was good.
I mean,
he went up there,
there was a microphone,
he was talking into it.
You could understand what he was saying.
Um,
he seemed to be having a good time.
What was he talking about?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I can't,
that's the thing I can't really remember,
but it was definitely English.
I know that because at no point I,
I wasn't not comprehending what he was saying.
So I'm,
whatever,
I'm putting a little bit of pressure on myself.
I just,
you know the fuck you got to keep trying to top yourself and a,
when you have a limited amount of skills that mentally,
you know,
and I know it's a weird thing,
try and turn to beat yourself.
How do you fake out yourself?
You know,
am I making any God damn sense right now or is this fucking theraflu still a
kicking in here?
I'm actually fighting this shit off duty.
You want to talk?
I do this overrated underrated thing here on the podcast.
You don't,
you want to talk a underrated,
underrated taking vitamins every God damn day,
which is what I've been doing lately.
You know,
I take a,
I take a men's multivitamin.
I don't even know what it is.
I just know it's a brown with little black freckles of shit on it.
I have no idea what it is I've been taking that is vitamin B supplements.
So I don't get Alzheimer's because evidently,
uh,
I took a physical and they were telling me not even gonna say that cause I'm
trying to get health insurance right now.
That's the preexisting condition.
Now we brought that up.
Well,
maybe it's the all timers.
Maybe that's why you don't remember it.
MMM.
Yeah.
That's the how kind of health insurance I have right now.
And I want to get some other health insurance.
The health insurance I have right now basically covers everything except what I
go,
you know,
to the dentist for,
I want to get a fucking cleaning and they didn't cover it.
I mean that's ground zero.
And they're saying because the lady use that,
that electronic pick,
which a lot of them use just because they're lazy,
not they lazy.
They did,
you know,
back in the old days whether you suggest use the scraper,
the,
the manual scraper for your teeth.
Now they just,
they use the,
uh,
the other one,
I mean,
I hadn't gone in in a little bit.
So the first time I went in I understood that she used it,
but now I've been going in there like every fucking four months,
you know,
four months.
You don't need to use that electronic one.
You fucking lazy.
But for some reason my health insurance,
oh,
we only,
we only just cover if they just use with use it with their hands.
Yeah.
By the way,
you owe us another 350 bucks for this quarter.
I'll go fuck yourselves.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
I am on tour like a maniac right now.
Um,
not like a maniac,
like someone's getting ready to do a special.
So I am actually in New York City right now sitting in my old apartment and uh,
it's bringing back memories of when I used to fucking live here and I would get
shit faced and bang a whore.
MMM.
I like this place.
I'm going to try and keep it,
you know,
this is my just in case I get divorced place someday,
cause I'll go out and buy a house and God knows my girl will get that,
you know?
And then Phil,
our kids up with her version of who am,
you know,
then I come by on Saturdays to pick them up and then they got that look on their
face,
you know,
like they just had some horrific story told to them.
Wow,
man.
I'm really in a bad mood right now.
Just not even a bad mood.
I'm just fucking negative.
You know what?
Why don't we try and turn this around by me giving you guys,
I'll do a little ass bill hill bill here.
I didn't know what.
Fuck that.
Why don't I hype what I have coming up this weekend?
I have,
I'm going to be at the Improv in a,
I think it's homestead,
Pennsylvania,
right outside of Pittsburgh.
It's called the the stacks,
I believe it's that mall right it right up,
right over the bridge that goes over the river.
Get Out.
It's basically one of those things.
It's classic America right now.
It's basically,
it's a place where Americans used to have union jobs and they made steel for
fucking American cars in American buildings and now it's a mall and you go in
there and you buy shit that was made from people in other countries,
probably by their children for one 90th of what they were paying an American,
but as a tribute to those Americans are used to have jobs.
They kept it.
They kept the smokestacks from the old steel factory steel mill factory.
Actually the last time I was fucking there,
I actually kind of researched that area cause I was kind of fascinated by it.
And I found out that there was some big,
big battle between the workers and they called in police and the and some
militia to beat down these Americans who wanted to get a fair wage and people
got their heads split open.
They fucking died right there on those riverbanks,
you know,
so people could make money and I don't know what happened.
My generation,
we just sat around eating double cheeseburgers and an all fucking left.
But anyways,
I'll be down there telling my jokes,
hey and look Uzbek,
look who's back,
ladies and gentlemen,
Joe to Rosa Young Joe de Rosa and Joe,
you know I'm gonna love about Joe is Joe's actually going to come in,
he's going to join the podcast and at no point is he ever going to address that.
We actually already did this podcast for 45 minutes before I realized that I
didn't have any batteries in my recorder and he's going to sit down like a God
damn pro
this and this is the deal.
People always ask me,
you know,
what in the hell are you ever going to have a guest?
Every once in a while he should switch it up.
You should get a guest like got a guest,
a disgruntled,
I already did this for free for 45 minutes.
Joe,
let me tell you something,
man,
you was so funny this past hour on this podcast that didn't get recorded.
Thank you.
And I have belief in you that there's a lot more funny in that.
Well,
Joe is actually a,
if you're new to the podcast,
I'm,
Joe is a,
this is the worst joke cause I've already done this and it's fucking Monday.
I'm sorry sir.
All Right Joe,
right?
Still worse.
We gave that guy great advice and now right now we're going to have to read it
again and pretend like we already didn't fucking do it or it will be fine.
We'll get through it.
We'll get through it when we tell you an inspirational story,
Joe,
so we can get through this the second time.
Brian Johnson of ACDC fame,
all right.
One time told the story about Phil Rudd,
the drummer,
their band.
And he said basically they had some unbelievable take us some song and for some
reason they ran out of tape right in the moment,
right in the middle of the greatest part of the song ever.
And it had been built to like this emotional apex,
you know,
so the guy goes,
either guide the fucking guy behind the,
uh,
the mixing board is all devastated and he's apologetic and he's like,
I can't believe in some out,
whatever.
They have to somehow get,
they lost Phil Rudd Shit,
right?
All right.
And the guy's like,
oh my God,
we're never going to get it today.
Fucked up.
I'm so sorry.
And then Phil Rub was just like,
just play the tape again,
mate.
I'm going to jump right in.
And he goes,
there's no way you can do it.
He goes,
just roll the fucking tape.
And they roll it to it and he jumps in seamlessly.
Like he went back in time and he fucking totally nails the take plays it even
fucking better than they did the first time they hit,
they stopped the thing and the fucking guy behind the board,
he's just completely flabbergasted cause cause I was on blue,
I'd never seen anybody do anything like that.
You're,
you're fucking unbelievable.
And Phil was sitting there with that cigarette Dang dangling from his lips and
he just goes,
I know
Brian Johnson tells it better,
but that's your inspirational story.
They had Joe.
So anyways,
Joe Derosa,
me and Joe do this.
There's wonderful radio show that used to be on Xm.
He used to be on Xm Sirius.
Yeah,
sometimes it is.
But you know what?
I Dunno.
There was a merger and just like you guys out there going through this tough
economy,
I guess we were the odd man out there was a merger.
They took our money away,
they left us with nothing.
You know what they really did?
And we just decided we would tire to wait nine months for a fucking $35 check.
Isn't that what basically I'll be honest here.
Oddly enough we,
we,
we see more disappointed than Xm does.
Yeah.
About the show.
And we keep reading the trade magazines waiting for that Xm Sirius,
Sirius Xm X.
I was there.
It was called to say what happened where whatever you're saying that their stock
plummeted another two fucking is it points at dollars.
We don't know what the points.
So tell us,
let's go with points anyways,
the name of the show,
we do what's called uninformed,
uh,
no reading,
no research,
just strong opinions.
And if you haven't picked it up yet,
me and Joe were a couple of fucking morons and at no point should you ever
really listened to anything that we say and you know,
why do we do,
we don't.
We really do our show for other than to Horace sells out so we can make more
money and not have to go on the road shaking hands of people who have fevers
that are then going to pass it on to you as you can get to wash your hands and
eat a fucking order of Mozzarella sticks between the first and second shelf like
I did.
Um,
who,
who do we,
who else do we do it for?
You should you know who is what?
We do it for the first,
sorry,
I'm sorry.
I have no train of thought.
We fucking,
we do it for you.
For you of my 15 fucking listeners so you guys can feel better about your life.
Yeah,
no,
not even advice.
Just when you hear a fucking stupid we are,
you can actually and mean like,
well these guys actually have some sort of hat fast radio show.
You know.
I can make it too.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's good.
It makes people feel like they can achieve out there.
Yeah,
they made it makes people feel like they can get to our level cause you
certainly can.
This is an attainable level in life.
Absolutely.
We are not,
well,
I'm speaking for myself.
Yeah.
You know,
but you too can be on the internet making no money whatsoever and not have a
boss is something freeing about it.
Joe.
John Tell you all we need is a windmill and our own garden in the back and what?
We'll be fucking good.
Well just go veggie.
What would you plant in the garden bill?
Oh,
do you like a cup of Cherry tomatoes?
Tomatoes.
Let me tell you something.
Do you know how bad I want to buy a fucking house so I can have a garden?
I love having gardens.
I want to,
I want to have a garden and be,
that guy was slowly loses his mind out there talking to the plants because he's
breathing into pesticides.
You know?
That's who I want to be.
Just,
Oh look at that.
Zucchini shaped like a girl.
I used to know
my,
uh,
my dad had a pet,
an astounding garden when I was growing up.
I think that that's one of the coolest things ever to be able to walk in your
backyard.
Okay.
Like and have your own food supply.
I think there's something really like,
I think that we've kind of got everybody living in a culdesac.
I really think that,
you know what I would love to do,
you know,
you would get wet by the fucking powers that be,
but if you could just somehow teach people how to build windmills and if they
somehow just couldn't stop it,
you know,
the same way like fucking that debt auto,
auto tron,
what the fuck?
What kind of music is that took over,
you know that music Jay z's rather tune auto tune the same way that that just
took over and the government couldn't do anything about it.
Like what if,
what if people just started windmills?
You can build a windmill.
That's not illegal now you can't,
sure you can and you can't.
Why?
Because um,
general electric is worried that you're not going to make one that's safe.
So they still need to go out there and inspect it to make sure now they did a
whole fucking thing out in California where they,
once again,
they squeezed out the little guy and this is what they're doing.
Joe,
as we move into a greener ways,
as we're moving into the reason why it's taking so fucking long for us to move
into greener things is because first of all there's still a lot more money to be
made with the old things and then also the guide,
the the fuck and there will be blood guys.
Got To make sure that they're still in control of it.
You know?
That's my fucking solution to the Middle East.
You want to beat those cock suckers over there.
Just fucking make cars run on fruit loops or water or whatever the fuck we can't
all be and people can do it.
Stand mayor came up with something on a long island.
How to make you make it run on water.
Okay.
How do these fucking terrorists get their money?
As far as I know,
Joe and I don't know a lot.
I believe that the money that we on all their fucking oil goes to the,
did the,
had a rab over there,
the head,
the,
the fucking Shah or whatever the fuck he's called.
And then he sits there and acts like he's down with America while he subtly is
sending money off to the Hamas and the al Qaeda and all that.
So we stopped fucking using that.
That God damn energy,
they'd go bankrupt over there.
You ain't got no money,
Joe Yank got no boots.
You ain't got no poo.
She ain't got no guns.
What does that for?
Uh,
we ain't got no boobs,
but we had kind of woods.
Was that from Kelly's heroes or sarcoid?
Telly Savalas or is it from dirty?
That was telly Savalas yelling at fucking,
uh,
Don Rickles.
You never saw Kelly's heroes.
Oh,
Kelly's heroes is a fucking great movie.
And it's hilarious because it doesn't make sense because it's about World War
II,
but it has the hippie Vietnam vibe.
It's right during that time with the directors took over in Hollywood.
You're like,
fuck it.
We're going to do it our way.
Yeah.
Did you know up until like that,
like for the longest time that the director's job was basically only to make
sure that the actors were on there,
mark and that everything was in frame.
I don't even think they were responsible to make sure about the lines.
Now there was the studio's operated like factories,
dude.
Yeah.
And the second you said,
and that's a wrap.
You left and the studio took the picture and they cut it up.
It's amazing.
Right?
That's why guys like Billy Wilder were so renowned in the,
uh,
cause he did that in the 50s right?
Yeah.
He was being a real director in the 50s you know what I mean?
That was it Craig.
So basic,
what happens?
So at the Kelly's heroes thing,
by then what you had was you had that young generation that was taking over and
they will making a World War II movie.
And they had Kiefer Sutherland played down southern,
sorry,
Donald Sutherland was playing this hippie a this sorta,
you know,
they had like their own,
like,
uh,
they had their own way of doing things,
man.
But it was funny.
It was before hippies became like played out and annoying.
You know who's like head guy?
Gavin Macleod,
isn't it?
Who's the head guy that Clint Eastwood,
Clint Eastwood Dude.
They got all the guys,
guys,
Clint Eastwood,
Telly Savalas,
Don Rickles,
Donald Sutherland.
Uh,
I think that guy who played angel on the Rockford files is in it.
I can't remember.
Gavin Macleod who used to be on May.
Hey,
they may used to play Mary Tyler Moore here from the love boat,
right?
Yeah,
he's from Mary Tyler Moore,
the love boat that was,
that was saying,
he's the captain of the love boat and that was his cash grab.
He's like,
I'm old.
I can't believe I keep getting work.
But that little fucking mustaches,
a little pair of shorts being all tanned up,
little white shorts to the greatest exit in non flame out from drugs ever was
the guy who played gopher on the love boat.
Dude,
you're on a show.
It's called the love boat.
Your character's name is gopher and you're wearing shorts like you're on a
cruise ship with those white sox yanked up to your fucking knees or the Aba.
Right.
Okay.
Your career is over.
You're going to take all anybody else,
any less of a fucking man would've taken all that money.
Okay.
You would have found Donnie most and you would've sent it up your fucking nose.
I shouldn't have sent him.
He didn't do that.
Trucks,
whatever you find out.
Lawrence McCutcheon or whatever her name is Kenzie fit.
Yet Lawrence McCutcheon is an old running back from fucking the Baltimore Colts.
But anyways,
that's what you would do.
He had the fucking wherewithal to be like,
I'm Gofer.
I'm on the love boat.
This is it.
What else do I want to do?
I'm into politics.
He went on,
he became a fucking state senator.
Which one was go for the black guy?
No,
that was Isaac Hayes.
W I know it wasn't.
It was Isaac Curtis.
That's another fight.
You,
Isaac Curtis was the fucking wide receiver for the no,
no,
no.
Or seismic?
No,
you don't.
Who the fuck that was?
Oh,
you mean,
you know what's funny about which were when we went and got a great,
which one was go for the hold on,
go for was the guy with the glasses.
Now the doctor who got all the pussy for no fucking reason,
that made no sense.
He had him.
Then you had Gavin Macleod,
then you had,
you had the bartender who did the double point.
That was the black guy now like a half the def jam headshots of the late
eighties I'm getting confused.
I'm getting day.
I mean he was he,
Gavin Macleod was the ball guy.
I would say mustache.
I was getting Barney Miller confused with Gavin Macleod.
Oh yeah.
Dude and I,
he was probably on that fucking show.
The point is,
there was a guy on that show,
he was a series regular.
His name was,
go for it.
The dark hair.
Yes.
Okay.
I remember now let's,
let's go through,
let's go through some sitcoms.
Joe,
let's name awful character names where you know you're not Urkel Dun,
Dun Schneider.
Schneider done like when?
When?
When you don't skippy Outta here.
Skippy family ties stopped doing Carmody now.
Yeah.
Joe.
Yes he is.
Squealer when it was,
what was that kid on fucking saved by the bell screech.
Screech sweetly.
I'm still dumbfounded that I,
when you said Lawrence,
what did you call as Mccutcheon?
Cause it's so good.
I knew it was mackenzie.
That's so close though.
It was like some sort of pig Latin.
Wait a minute,
they're all done.
Potsy pots and done Ralph mouth done.
Every actor in Hollywood and Fonzie even Fonzie's done.
This is the thing.
Oh,
squigy squigy out of here.
Out of there.
This is the thing as,
as a fucking,
as an actor,
you have to instinctively know that if your character does not have a first and
a fucking last name,
it's already be doing this please.
It's,
it's already going to be.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Joe will melt this as much as we can and it's still actually recording.
Dude,
if you don't have like a real fuck and a name that you could walk out in public.
Alex p Keaton.
Okay.
He kept going.
He just had the unfortunate of getting sick and he was even sick and he was able
to do a west wing spin city.
They both about the same shit,
dude.
I watch sports.
I don't watch that.
The West Wing is about the White House.
Vincent,
he was about him working for a governor.
It's politics.
You just be happy.
I didn't say Benson again.
I it,
there you go Ben.
There's one God.
Ooh Benson.
The fuck is that guy died.
What does Robert Gom done since Benson?
Yeah,
but he was,
he was like 70 when he finally got that and I'll do it.
I'm talking.
Good.
Sit here.
Pence is not a bad name.
I guess somebody came in and the guy said,
my name is Benson,
but you're saying on one name character gone.
Dude,
I'm,
I'm more talking about like you need your name is fucking zippy.
Big Ragu gone.
See you later.
The Big Ragu gone.
Uh,
who was the guy,
uh,
that a on family ties?
Nick.
Nick,
his name wasn't Mousse.
No,
it was nick.
His name was nick on the show.
Is Moose Moose from that fucking show.
With those duckets show would they would step out of the locker television.
Yeah.
That was moose.
But hey to her,
hey Jerry.
Yeah.
Moose.
She didn't even look like a most,
yeah,
it was just such a mean nickname.
It really wasn't mic.
Yeah.
I love that show that there was a great show these to torture kids.
Remember they did the firing squad,
they'd shoot the kids and shit.
That was a great show.
Red Now.
Yeah.
They did these to do a sketch.
It was on Nickelodeon and they used to do a sketch where they had that one guy
that played all the grownups on the show.
He was the one actor and he would fish.
He did like,
he would do like a Nazi character.
And he was like Eddie last verse.
And the kid would say something and he'd make a one liner and they'd shoot the
kid.
And then they,
he did another character called barf where he ran a restaurant and he was
disgusting.
It would always pick his nose and the kids eat.
And there would be like,
you know,
they would go,
uh,
they'd say something like,
you know,
I saw dead squirrel in the street when I was on my way in here.
And then barf would pop up and you go,
uh,
what do you think's in the Burger?
That was his catchphrase that he's putting nasty shit number.
So needless to say,
he never worked again.
What was his character's name?
He was the guy that played all the male grown up care.
He played every,
can I tell you when I was in a,
when I was working in Denver,
um,
I'm doing,
I made a reference to family ties and at the end of the show,
this guy comes up to me tatted out,
tattoos all over him and he's fucking twitching a little bit.
And he goes,
Hey,
uh,
and his buddy comes up going,
hey,
you like family ties,
right?
He's like,
yeah,
this kid was one of the guys on it.
And I'm looking at him,
he didn't like in his twenties.
And I'm like,
what the fuck was he?
He played the little kid.
Why was he twitching?
Uh,
he said you probably saw me on TV getting arrested for drugs and drinking and
driving.
I've been sober for six months and so his buddy who's hanging out with them when
to take one at a picture with me.
So we go to take
a picture and that the former child star there is holding the camera's hands are
shaking and the kid with me goes,
look,
look at his handshake and look at his hand shaking and it really fucking pissed
me off and I want to be like,
you know what to do this kids just hanging out with you because you're fucking
you right now.
Like he shouldn't be saying that.
If that's a true friend,
who the fuck would be saying that this kid is trying to be sober and he's making
funny.
Your fucking hands twitching and he's just a total cunt and he's just trying to
get a picture with me because I've been on,
I love the eighties she's fucking pathetic level star fucker.
He's like half a star fucker.
Yeah.
I just remember that stuck on it really annoyed me and I felt bad for that kid.
You could just,
you know,
you know something to do.
Do you know why it take some of those stuff?
Those the child star kids flame out is because what kind of a fucking kid wants
to have to memorize lines?
Like who tries to make it at five?
There were a kid did it right man.
The youngest kid from home improvement taxi driver.
A Cynthia Phillips.
Cindy Williams.
No,
not her fucking uh,
uh,
be beaver.
Beaver clam.
What?
Jodie foster going about Jodie foster.
Beaver cleaver.
Clamp that.
How does that have to do it?
Just that those rooms,
she was gay.
I would say.
Oh,
that's my like me brainstorm.
That's how I get,
I get it wrong.
Trying to be like,
am I was sounding,
I'm a homophobe homophobic.
I was trying to give you clues.
I go,
what I do and I can't remember shit.
I just start acting like I'm on the $10,000 pyramid.
Beaver clan,
Jodie foster.
I'm telling you what kid did it right.
Was the youngest kid from a home improvement.
I watched one of those Hollywood,
you know,
children are Hollywood specials or whatever and he uh,
he left the business.
He just walked away when the,
when it was done,
he didn't care anymore.
Yeah,
he went out.
He married some girl.
He followed some girl.
Who is this?
I wasn't even listening in the beginning.
The youngest kid from home improvement.
The one,
the youngest kid like he's like earth.
Michael Taylor Thompson.
No,
no,
no.
He was the middle kid.
He he went to see the body.
No,
no,
no.
The youngest kid.
I hated that show too.
I look,
I'm not talking,
I forget that part of it.
I'm just saying he left show business as a child star.
It was like fuck it,
I'm out of here.
He went out to the Midwest.
He started deejaying cause that's what he wanted to do.
He married some shit way,
way,
way.
What?
He started deejaying.
Hey started,
he just like started deejaying for fun.
Debbie tell you have a problem with white guy.
Shit Dj and they opened a Vegan restaurant and he was like,
this is what I do is my life.
I live a very pure healthy life.
Like he just had it.
He was just so collected.
There was not an,
he was again,
maybe one day I'll go back and hang.
I don't know,
whatever man.
Like he just didn't care.
He wasn't one of these fucking,
you know Dana Platos which guy was it?
Cause I've got to tell you something.
Those kids,
I don't know if they would take an HGH,
but something happened to the skulls of the kids on that show.
What show that home improvement and then nothing happened in luck.
And they looked like they weren't fun house mirrors by the end of it.
They were going through puberty and they did.
They have fucking foreheads would jut now they've did.
They were adorable kids when they first got,
that's the thing about,
about like you get those kids is the puppies.
This,
you're very hard pressed to find a puppy that isn't cute,
but you know you can have an ugly dog.
And that's what I'm saying.
A lot of those kids were ugly dogs.
Yeah.
They kind of turned like yet like I think at least two of the three kids on home
improvement.
We're on roids thank Jonathan Taylor Thomas,
you're still a pretty decent looking kid.
He was,
he had the pianist,
he looked like,
yeah,
that composer hair.
He looked like it was in bugs bunny.
Like he was going to
like,
I can't get tails on go.
You should always be wearing tales.
You know,
you don't know where to actually tapping into right now.
Joe Is my fucking memory problem.
Like I can't remember people's names and I can't remember the names of places.
Like there's a breakfast place.
Me and Nia love out now,
the west coast and they have like these big,
huge biggest pancakes you ever saw in your life.
Biggest French toast and always putting like whipped cream and all this shit and
it's fucking ridiculous.
May Hump Right,
but you eat it,
huh?
Here's your always against eaten shit.
Like yeah I am,
but there's their French toast dude is ridiculous and I don't do like the
whipped bite.
I just see people going by and they got like a whole stick of butter on it and
we've been at 200 times.
I can't remember the fucking name of the place you remember right now?
No.
I finally remembered it's called the griddle,
but for the longest time I was called,
I was calling it a pancake circus.
I liked the griddle.
I'd been there.
Oh,
I do.
This is what I'm trying to explain you why I say the composer because what I,
I can,
I remember certain details.
I remember he had that long fucking Beethoven haircut.
So then it becomes that.
That's really fun.
And then what it does is then I throw it out there and then you go,
no,
no.
And then you say the name and I kind of,
I'm able to joke my way through the fact that I can't remember shit.
I'm with you.
I'm with you pal.
Yeah,
Deb,
buddy.
I want to help you get through this.
Get through this bill.
I just realized I am fucking star Dude.
I know.
I feel like I'm going to pass out.
No offense,
but how much longer?
How much longer do I have to do free?
She was free.
So technically I can fucking cut it off whenever I can,
whenever I want to.
Why don't we what Joe,
when,
when are we actually going to be able to start?
Me and Joe Derosa as you've noticed,
have just a tremendous chemistry when we get on the microphones and shit.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
On the one and two,
um,
yeah,
that's where we do that podcast.
So,
so listen,
so we're,
we're going to start doing these on a show.
Why can't we upload these fucking things onto the internet?
Look,
here's the,
we had this show called uninformed and then we started to do it as a podcast and
we're going to sell it for a buck and episode on the web.
I mean,
on iTunes.
Yeah,
because we're actually going,
I can't get the guidance things to upload.
Let me,
let me,
let me jump in here.
And the reason why we're charging a dollar an episode people is because we're
actually going to have guests.
We're going to have interviews,
we're going to be doing things.
I mean it's a fucking radio show and I know you people on the Internet don't
like to pay for Shit.
It's a dollar an episode for the love of God.
You know it was up there.
Was that the fucking worst way ever to try?
I love how just nowadays as an artist you have to justify that,
that you know that your time is valuable.
Even if we don't have guests,
which we will have episodes where we don't,
you know,
we used to get paid to do the show.
It's work to do the show.
We have to,
we have to book gigs on the road to go to that bar and I want to find that guy
who came up with that cheeseburger and talked to him and just talk to him just
about food in general.
There's a government agent tried to take that guy out right now.
No,
he isn't loving works for them.
Look,
Joe,
your weight,
we talked about that cheeseburger and the last one.
I don't think you got it on this.
Did I not talk about it in this one?
Oh,
I didn't know came member.
All right.
This is,
this is,
this is a fucking,
okay.
Just to fucking go back.
I talked about that fried butter a week ago and how like did this just insane
levels of like why,
okay.
I was in,
I was watching the Patriots game yesterday.
Joe.
Uh,
Shit.
I know you're a big sports fan.
You know that they one bill.
Then another day one that we got lucky against the ravens again,
the ravens have beaten us the last two times we played them and somehow,
I don't know what happens.
They fucking,
they make a bonehead play.
They played and they pull it out of pocket.
I would say that patriots,
they could,
they pull it out in the pocket.
I'll tell you.
No one can talk sports like Joe Joe.
Why did the Patriots beat the Ravens?
Because their Gi bill overall,
I just think they're a better team and when they're put under the gun,
they deliver.
You can actually get away with that on a,
on a sports talk show.
Yeah.
It's another one.
You have to incorporate it.
This is another thing.
If somebody asks you what's wrong with the Patriots?
All you've got to start,
as I got to tell you,
if I'm the Patriots right now,
I gotta be thinking and then just you don't have that.
All you gotta do is just throw anything in there and you'll be fine.
I'll tell you two things that,
two things I've been right about.
Two things that I called this season,
Joe was everyone was fucking jumping all over Sanchez,
the jets quarterback,
you know him?
Yeah.
Well Sanchez is heat on that guy for no reason.
And uh,
you know,
I think he's a good player.
I mean deserves a little leeway.
I like how you just said two things that,
no,
I said in the beginning of the season,
I mean they called the guy a star up there.
He beat the Texans.
I mean,
he's going to be a star.
It's not a star yet.
And I called it with my buddy.
I said,
dude,
he is going to have that horrific pick six.
I'm a fucking rookie.
And he had it yesterday and I also called Matt Cassel when they sent them over
to Kansas City.
And everyone's like,
how the fuck are the Patriots?
Get rid of him.
I said he was driving a Ferrari last season.
That's all he had to do was keep it on the fucking road and he went 11 and five
right now you're going to Kansas City.
All of a sudden you're not driving a Ferrari anymore.
No,
you don't even drive it to z 28 you've got to Camaro rally sport.
That's what you got with the v six and your chicks drive in it.
What I like about Matt Cassel,
this Matt,
Karen's real players player and all right,
let's,
let's end that.
Let's do a new segment.
Just sports [inaudible] sports talk with shoulder rose.
We'll just fake sports talk for as long as I can.
I'll just be you.
You talk real sports and I'll,
I'll just fake through it.
I think we got it.
Joe.
I think me and the listeners understood the premise while you were doing it.
Joe,
what may Tony Dorsett the running back that he was Tony Doors set,
you know,
you know he had the legs of a champion.
He's just a guy who could run no matter what he could run.
And that's the most important thing when a running back is that they run.
These guys are out here talking about his style.
John,
talk about his style.
Is it running back?
Like who,
who would you compare him to?
His style look.
Uh,
you know,
when running backs,
I'm looking for a Mike Quick,
uh,
I'm looking for a guy that drills and runs that guy head down,
shoulders up.
He knew how to plow through it.
And that's what you need.
Delivery to the end zone.
No,
it's amazing.
It's how you will almost fucking,
you're almost,
you're saying it's fucked up enough where people would still be looking at each
other like,
dude,
this guy doesn't watch sports.
But then you right.
As you think that,
then you're like,
oh,
maybe he does head down.
That makes sense.
Shoulders up.
How do you have a head down and you say,
how do you have,
all right,
yeah,
let's,
let's get back to the sandwich before this whole thing goes off the rail.
So I'm sending it this fucking Bar,
right?
Cause that's what I do.
Do I drink during the day?
Let's let's,
you know,
I don't have anything to live for.
It's all about killing the silence,
what the road is.
I will say it's just waiting for the next meal.
Just waiting for the next week for the next meal.
Please share the clank of the silverware.
That's all you want to do.
Joe Killed The loneliness.
All right,
so let's plow ahead here.
So I'm sitting at this bar,
right?
And I'm watching the game with this guy and this guy calls the bartender order
over to order some food and he goes,
yeah,
listen,
I want to order you.
Sure.
I didn't tell it on this one.
I'm not positive,
but I'm pretty sure tell it again.
Yeah,
it gives a shit.
Such a great,
yeah,
cause we were talking about,
remember it,
let us on that a KFC shit and everything.
We didn't play it today.
Right?
That shit.
All right.
So anyway,
so the guy calls a bartender over and he goes,
yeah.
I goes,
yeah,
listen,
I want to order a custom burger.
And I'm like,
who the fuck does that?
Who the fuck is accustomed bird?
Well,
evidently this guy had this burger at this bar in New Jersey.
It's called a duck buster.
D.
U C K.
Buster.
I gotta give these guys credit because they really went above and beyond.
So evidently this dude ate it and he loved it so much.
He goes to this bar and he goes to order at some listening to him order and the
guy goes,
all right,
what do you want?
He goes,
all right,
this is what I want you to do.
It's like that Jack Nicholson thing.
I want you to hold it between your knees.
It's like that fucking thing.
He,
he basically goes,
I want you to make two grilled cheese sandwiches with tomato and bacon in them
because to grow yet to grilled cheese sounds just with tomato and Bacon and,
and then I want you to you to use those two grilled cheese sandwiches as the
bread for the cheeseburger.
So the two sandwiches where the bun and then he see,
you were totally blown away the first time,
but you already heard it.
So it's just gets through the,
and then he,
then he had another fucking,
and then he had like a half pound of beef in there with cheese on of that.
And I will say it again.
That sounds amazing.
And if I could get it right now,
I'd go get it.
The problem is we're getting that.
The problem is the product cost them $20 because you know,
yeah,
that's like two,
two words of a grill.
This is what,
you know what y'all,
I would eat that I really gel.
Yeah.
I like,
I didn't fucking know that I would eat it.
You know what I,
one time I was sitting in shooting the shit with Joe and I didn't realize until
he got to his second donut that he was actually just sitting across from me
eating a bag of donuts,
donuts.
It was like two in the afternoon.
Joe,
what I've seen you on many occasions eat pancakes with chocolate chips and shit.
No,
you have a banana.
Bananas.
That's good for you.
But that's for two pancakes.
No worse than the God damn doughnut dude.
It's front and not at her.
Joe,
what?
I don't have the knowledge to fucking actually backup that.
I know I'm right.
Pancakes are not as bad as donuts.
Donuts,
you're trying to get fat.
You're trying to get for take a stack of pancakes.
You put butter and syrup on them.
You think that's that?
Any the stack beginning works.
It's fucking pure sugar.
Having an orgy with butter.
What's it a pancake?
Pure center.
It's not pure sugar.
Doughnuts are better there than not.
John,
let me tell you something now,
but don't you know,
don't you don't you fuck you.
Don't.
You don't how to make one Joe.
You've,
you've made a donut bill.
It's better that you deep fry it.
Sugar coagulating with butter.
That's all it is.
Bill.
You're wrong.
I am not wrong.
You're making this up.
I'm gonna kick you off this fucking show.
I got wrong on my own podcast.
Rip a no,
but it's,
it's bred.
Do they know what is your content?
It's not as bad as a pancake.
Doe Not healthy,
but it's not as bad as the pain.
First of all,
fuck.
Shut up one doughnut at 2:00 PM.
It's the same thing.
Fucking face.
You're wrong,
Joe.
First of all,
a fucking does nothing.
Don't you don't disrespect pancake.
No,
I don't ever.
I have a fucking Pankey,
you know pancakes.
Pancakes.
I like that buddy of yours who you don't want anybody to talk shit about.
But you know this slightly retarded.
That's what pancakes off from me.
That's how I used to fucking,
no,
you don't understand the rules.
You like to go to your little fucking pen.
No,
that's not a,
that's how I used to make money on the road when I was on the road and I wasn't
making shit.
And I'm out there by my fucking self not talking to anybody back the fly.
Even had a fucking cell phone.
Joe.
A lot of people didn't have cell phones in the late nineties I was one of them.
Okay.
And I fucking why be out there in the middle of goddamn nowhere.
No,
actually by then I got a cell phone,
but I've been so in the middle of nowhere.
It was like on that roaming thing,
and this is how I would make money cause I wasn't making any fucking money
because what I would do is I would either go to Denny's or I would go to the I
hop and I would get their large stack of five and dude,
it is not sugar.
It's like fucking cement.
And you would just pour that in and it would mold to the shape of your stomach
and it would sit there and do,
do you eat that at fucking eight,
nine in the morning and then go do nooner and then drive to Colorado schools are
the mines or some fucking Rhinelander Wisconsin fucking Gig.
And you would not be hungry for 12 hours.
And that way I was able to skip meals and,
and I,
and I could cut down on my food costs.
Okay,
you tell me you eat a sack of fucking donuts in the morning and you can go 12
hours without eating.
You can't.
First of all,
you'd pass out behind the fucking wheel because of all that sugar.
And you know,
that's fucking true.
Joe,
I want you to retract your statements.
Pop pancakes.
I will know you will deal with the ramifications of this Joe,
because I have podcasts listeners and they are very vocal.
They email.
I uh,
it's not as bad as a fucking doughnut.
This is what you're,
you're not listening to what I'm saying.
I'm saying a statue annoy makes is banded one donut and let's say in a pile of
donuts is equal to a pile of pinkish.
Okay.
Wait a minute now I need a stack of pancakes.
No,
that's as bad as eating one doughnut.
I disagree.
Let's look it up on the Goddamn Internet.
Raul.
Look Joe.
Cause cause what you're doing is you're equating quality,
uh,
calories to being equally bad.
Okay.
Look Gel.
Shush.
Shush you.
I did Joe.
I can eat.
I can eat fucking 400 calories of apples and you can eat 400 calories of
doughnuts.
What the fuck is worse built pancakes or not?
There's up.
You're going to shit yourself,
Joe.
There's just nothing about pancakes that are good for you though.
All right,
shit.
They got you can,
do they ever put fucking bananas or any sort of fruit on the side when you get a
donut they don't.
You put fruit to put blue.
Would a delicious,
delicious fruit.
Do you know what that time to make the donuts guide Jesus and to him,
that's what the fucking fill out,
whatever is.
Every once in a while I'd like to be a first grader bill.
I like a little donut here and there.
You know there's nothing wrong with it.
I think a lot of like how you're saying it like you're like a finger in your
ass.
Well I like that too.
All right,
let's move on here.
Okay.
All right,
let's go to the advice thing.
We have to actually do some.
So we've got 40 minutes here,
Joe and we,
we got,
we got to read this one again,
Joe.
Like it's the,
it's the first time we want,
I want to move beyond,
I have to do this because this guy wants to,
let's do this and then,
and then we got to eat something.
Dude,
I'm going to pass the fuck out of there now.
Joe,
why don't you just go shave your legs and get it done with you.
Fucking don't eat and pussy.
All right.
If you wanted this is,
yeah.
This will give them them a little taste of uninformed.
Yeah.
Just imagine if we were talking about global warming.
It was sounded this ignorant.
That is the uninformed show that's worth a fucking dollar,
isn't it?
It is.
God damn cheese.
It's hard to sell.
It's hard to sound this.
Never watched the Beatles.
They used to get chased down the street by their fans.
Now it's gone full circle when chasing fans.
Yeah.
Pleading with them to,
to give us a fucking measly dollar for our art.
I like how we're actually,
I'm actually acting like they refuse to do it without them even saying it.
I'm okay.
Bill.
First off,
I'm a huge fan of love.
The podcast.
I have a bit of a dilemma.
I'm 35 years old.
I have a 30 year old sister and I'm very protective of her.
She has a boyfriend that I used to be very tight with.
Um,
a few weeks ago,
we were coming back back from the cubs game,
even though the cock suckers lost the three of us.
We had a blast at that game,
but we were all kind of lit.
How many fucking nights have started this way?
Everybody's having a good time,
but you get a little drunk Joe.
Well,
let's try it.
Nice.
Nice fucking game.
Just fucking gets fucking the fucking game.
All right.
We're all kind of lit and on the way back,
I was sitting in the backseat of his car while he was driving.
Um,
I was doing that flick the ear thing and he was starting to get pissed.
So he's flicking this kid in the back of his ear as he's trying to drunk drive
down the street after their home team lost.
Okay.
That's how this story is beginning.
He goes,
I should have quit,
but I was buzzed.
Long story short,
we were at a light and I flicked him and then this can sucker.
He invented a curse word.
This can sucker punched me in the face,
knocked my tooth loose,
and I had to pull it out later.
All right.
First of all,
how hard did he flick them in the,
that's one of those things we,
you would trying to flick the year and then you cut the whole fucking year and
his ear was probably ringing.
So anyways,
he had to pull his tooth out later.
So he says,
after he cracked me,
I got out of the car and tried to pull him through his window in the middle of
traffic.
Um,
he locked the doors and rolled up his window.
My sister was started going nuts on me to get back in the car.
I didn't,
I don't claim to be a hard ass,
but I got to get my do,
I'm fucking losing sleep over this shit.
How do I explain to my sis that this shit has to be done without sounding like a
cave man?
He's been ducking me,
sent to census,
shit happen.
He's got to catch a beating and uh,
he will,
I just need to explain to my sis why this shit had to be done.
So basically his,
his,
his question is he stating that because even though he's flicking this kid in
the year,
the dude knocked his teeth out.
Okay.
He did it in front of his sister.
He's like,
this kid has to catch a beating is just some guy on guy guys understand this
shit.
How do I explain it to my sister so she doesn't think she can move beyond your
beating the shit out of my boyfriend.
Well,
I'm going to say this dude,
you're fucking,
we actually talked about why don't we just get catched cut to the chase.
You're five years older that your youngest sister,
you're protective over.
You know,
you don't like the fact that you wanted her to remain a virgin hair entire
fucking life.
But you knew in the back of your head that eventually a guy was going to be
coming along and as nice as this guy is,
and even though you get along with them in the back of your head,
you can't get past the fact that this guy's fucking your sister.
You know,
he's fucking your sister and there's nothing you can do about it.
So every once in a while when you get drunk,
that fucking hatred comes out in you and you start to be a little bit of a cunt
and you took it a little too far.
He was drunk,
you know,
Joe,
is there anything more annoying than somebody whacking you in the back of the
head is you're driving.
Okay.
He lost his shit.
He blasted you in the face.
You,
you fucking,
you deserve to do exactly.
What would you do if he was doing it to you?
Yeah.
You'd clock him in his fucking face and you deal with it.
That losing your tooth is payment for becoming an adult.
That's what that is.
You're not losing sleep because you want to get this guy back,
you losing sleep because you know you act like a fucking asshole and you got
Josie go easy.
Got You.
But it's it just because it's,
it's cause I also understand dude,
if some,
if I was looking somebody in the year and I lost my fucking two,
two,
I would want to kill the guy.
Don't put your hands on somebody now you don't put your hands on somebody,
man.
You just don't do that.
You put your hands on somebody,
you'd get what you deserve.
That's it.
You don't touch.
All right,
chill.
What if for some reason you were doing something that you were flicking me in
the back or whatever.
I don't know what the fuck and I turned around and I punched you in the face.
This guy gave him mornings.
Tell him stop.
You should stop doing it,
dude.
I would have stopped.
All right Joe.
Well,
let's see.
Let's,
let's do something here.
Okay,
I'm just being devil's are devil's advocate.
What would you rather have somebody flick your air 17 times or lose a tooth?
Be Honest.
Of course.
Flick my hair.
Right?
So what happened was,
what was his kid supposed to do?
They'll turn around and try to flick his ear back.
You know he did.
He did the right thing.
You,
he goes,
stop the kids not stopping.
He clocks him.
Finally,
Dude.
So what does he do?
So what,
what does he do?
What does what?
What is his,
how does nothing?
He acts like a,
this guy can't sleep Joe.
He gotta help them out.
Tell you,
I'll tell you how you get sleep again.
Grow Up.
Be a man.
Go to the guy.
Why did I invite you on this?
Go to the guy because you agree with dental and you know what?
No,
no,
no.
This is the thing,
Joe.
You don't,
you don't.
You know what?
You're a guest on the show.
I know my listeners look at this guy.
This guy is trying to justify beating the shit out of it.
Let me tell you,
this is what you gotta do,
Dude.
This is how you got to get him back in a silly way.
I hate to say this,
but what you're doing here dude,
is you're going to beat the shit out of that guy.
Okay?
And it's going to get ugly because you already feel like you have to do as much
damn equal damage.
Who's what?
You have to knock a fucking tooth of his out and that only that you're,
you're laying there awake stewing about this shit.
It's going to get,
it's going to be brutal.
You're going to beat the shit out of him and she's going to be screaming like
Sharon Stone in fucking casino when James Woods is getting the shit kicked out
of him.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's going to fuck up the holidays for years and if she ends up marrying,
this guy is going to be questions about whether you're going to be invited to
the,
to the,
to the wedding.
I totally understand why you've,
you're envisioning giving this guy an uppercut where all of his teeth climbing
together and they just crack like in a fucking cartoon.
You are not wrong for wanting to do that,
but you can't,
you cannot do that.
So,
um,
you got it.
You got to think of some sort of practical joke.
Like you got to say like,
look,
you got to be a man and be like,
I got out of line.
You knocked my tooth out and then this is what you could just decide a logical
towards.
You just say,
I'm not going to beat the shit out of you,
but no,
I am going to get you back.
So the years you're going to take off of his life while he's waiting for you to
do whatever the fuck you're going to do and don't damage his property.
I'm trying to think of something like,
I saw a guy on the Internet,
I saw a guy on the internet.
What?
It's bad advice.
I'm telling you,
dude,
well first of all,
this is all bad advice.
They shouldn't take any more advice.
What can I just show you something?
What he should do is demand thing to do here is go up to the guy and go,
look,
dude,
I'm a little pissed that you say it like you're missing a tooth.
And I have a speech impediment to say it that way.
Look through with a man.
I lost my tooth,
but I was looking in the ear,
look or Bari,
we're both anger upset because dude,
you gotta understand too.
The guy drive and he says at the beginning of the letter,
they were all drunk.
This guy is drunk driving.
He's,
he's trying to get this guy's flicking him in the fucking head.
That's all I got to go out this year,
right?
You know what,
dude?
You're being an asshole and you lost a tooth and you fucking embarrassed.
You got to look inward.
You're right,
Joe.
You know what?
You're right and fucking right.
He's,
he's got it.
He's got to like,
dude,
you know you got to,
you're not learning the lesson here.
You're not learning the lesson.
What you're doing is you're,
you're,
you're escalating.
You're absolutely right.
But listen,
I got to tell this because people say,
you know,
you've got to watch out when you give a advice because you got to know that
we're both a couple of fucking morons.
You know,
neither one of us has any,
we have no business giving out advice,
but you guys don't have the money during this economy to actually go to someone
who is smart too.
So I understand why you're asking me this,
but don't take my advice ever on this podcast.
All right,
this is how I do it and I'm doing this for free.
What are you going to sue me for?
My fucking Mexico.
You're not mentioning names,
you're not mentioning names.
So there's anonymity here and you're,
you're,
what you're telling the guy to do is nothing.
This is great Joe.
First of all,
you do you understand what just happened here?
We went from being complete non psychologists,
non therapist,
non fucking educated people here giving advice to then now Joe seamlessly.
You went from that to then giving me legal advice.
Do you realize you just did that?
Nope,
of course you did.
That's right.
I just talk.
I say what?
I need this right.
And you'd deliver with confidence and people believe it.
You know,
I realize what this advice,
people don't even want advice.
You know what they want.
They want to be encouraged because you know why Joe?
Because they're surrounded by a bunch of fucking cons.
I'm telling you,
it's not the al Qaeda,
it's not global warming.
It's the overwhelming amount of constant.
I tell you that I can't,
I can't tell this story.
I can't tell it,
but when I brought it up,
I got to change the city.
I got a chain.
Okay.
Let's say this happened fucking nine and a half weeks ago.
Yeah,
I know.
I got you.
I will.
I'll blow up.
But this is not fair to bring up a story and leave these fucking people.
Hang in here.
I'll just,
I'll give you the gist of it.
I'm fucking,
I got into a political debate with somebody.
Okay.
Who clearly I can.
I do.
You know,
I don't mind debating with people and I can be swayed.
Look,
I got swayed in that fucking argument.
Made a great God damn point.
I was a moron.
And you know,
sometimes I stick to my guns with the pancake thing.
You know,
I'm not a perfect person Joe.
Is that the beginning of an awful song?
I'm not a perfect person.
Yeah.
So why don't you just stop that and it's something that just,
just one of those sizes makes you want to punch every girl in the bar in the
face.
Cause they all start singing it sub types.
I stick to my guns.
I mean what he's singing,
but wait a minute,
this is what happened.
Somebody we got in this political debate and this person was making
moronic points just like I was,
but I was,
but I was delivering my moronic points in a car and a courtesy way and a
respectful way.
Right?
I'd be like,
you know,
we talk about,
I rack,
how the fuck do I go?
The only successful,
you know,
occupation I've ever seen has been this country.
And it's because we weren't leaving and we committed genocide.
So how do,
how do you win over there?
And I don't get it.
Did we just,
you know,
guys who just getting picked off over there and it's pissing me off,
right?
So she would make points on how we could win over there and then she,
and when after she was done making a point should go,
uh,
Duh.
Right?
Do you realize the arrogant level of that?
Like I do,
she's acting like,
for some reason the fucking super genius generals of our own fucking army of
this country.
They can't seem how to fucking finish it yet.
But this girl knows how to do it in the middle of nowhere.
And having never fought a war and to,
she kept sticking her head out going,
uh,
Duh.
Yeah,
she's doing,
she's doing the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the couch coach,
you know,
no,
she wasn't even what this and nothing to this is somebody who clearly,
you know,
just,
you can tell somebody they reek of not traveling that fucking their worldview
from their culdesac is fucking,
you know,
and if the and well,
who gives a shit?
I mean,
I'm acting like I'm a fucking genius.
I'm not,
but,
but at least I have the presence of mind to know that I'm a fucking moron,
so I will,
you know,
mate,
hey,
who I was arguing that pancake shit I knew in the back of the head,
I was probably wrong on stuff,
which is why I made a funny,
I would never be like,
Joe,
there's no sprinkles on pancakes.
A De stick.
Do you know what,
are you able to punch me in the face and I'd lose a tooth,
right.
Look at me and bringing it to false and that's our out.
That's how I for that.
That's how it happens though.
Don't you do that?
Don't you mock how I just got out of that?
No,
was no,
no.
I was saying,
there you go.
I'm,
I'll excited to get a sandwich.
I'm starving,
Joe.
Yeah.
Wait,
where did you get your basketball shorts?
I don't know.
Somebody gave them to me.
I know you don't play this.
I don't like how shiny they are.
Like you were an all star one year.
Like you're chewing gum.
I don't like him.
I just put them on because I don't care if I shut him up while I'm doing the
laundry.
Doing the work,
the laundry.
Laundry.
All right,
listen,
that's a,
there you go.
There's our first,
our first fucking guest ever.
Joe De Rosa and Joe Derosa in classic spirit of our wonderful radio show.
The uninformed show has now informed me that there's no difference between
pancakes and donuts.
He gave me legal advice,
anonymity.
We talk sports.
It was a good day.
Thanks for having me on,
man.
It was fun.
Okay.
Well I tell you Joe,
I really enjoy doing shows of deal and I really hope that people,
when we finally get these fucking episodes up,
which I will let you know on the,
uh,
on the,
on the podcast here,
cause this thing I just do as a goof or whatever as opposed to the uninformed
thing,
which is so fucking serious.
Um,
I'll let you know when it's up cause we really,
seriously,
man,
that's something that,
you know,
as much as my standup,
I want to build that radio show because I got to admit,
man,
I think it's just as good as anything else that's out there.
Yeah,
it's a got,
damn it,
it's worth a dollar to take a risk.
And if like usual,
I don't have any information of when it's going to be up,
but hopefully by next week,
Joe,
can you find some fucking tech nerd truck there?
I'm trying.
Trying a dude.
That's not what your outfits says.
You're off.
It says I quit a see.
Right.
Let's go get some pancakes.
You'll get a donut.
All right.
Thanks for listening to the uninformed,
I mean not on the form.
I'm sorry to the,
to the Monday morning podcast.
Why saw your cute face?
I thought that's what we were doing.
You guys all have a good week.
Hey,
I'm going to be at the uh,
the Improv in Pittsburgh this weekend.
I'm at the top of my game.
Motherfuckers,
I've been on the road for the last five weeks.
Okay,
so you,
you fucking strap in and put on your comedy hats and take that whistle between
your fucking toes.
Cause I'm bringing the comedy,
one of my hyping
Joe.
This is my podcast.
You're selfish cunt.
All right,
when are you going to be there?
But we get of October 23rd on the 23rd and 24th.
I'll be recording my CD at the stress factory for comedy central records,
stress factor,
New Brunswick,
New Jersey,
Jersey.
Please come out please.
23rd and 24th of October.
And I'll tell you this,
Joe,
I will argue they have the best Mozzarella sticks of any comedy club.
Dude,
it's the perfect combination where,
where the,
the outer layer is nice and crunchy.
And you know,
I hate the ones that had just all mush.
It's,
it's like you're reading like garlic bread that somebody dropped in a fry later.
So even if you don't like Joe's act,
you can sit there now.
Go check them out.
I,
uh,
I backed Joe.
Joe To roses is a funny motherfucker,
right?
You guys,
ah,
it wasn't that sweet.
All right,
everybody have it.
Great Week ticketing.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].